What's clear?
Our throats stuff is good.
We're live.
Let's it fuckers sit.
I'm pushing the fucking computer away.
I got throat coat tea.
That's right.
You're ready to go.
Billy Burger.
Hey,
that's like special out today out now.
That's right.
Walk your way out.
The ryman theater in Nashville.
Tanush safe.
That's where they used to do Grand Ole
opry is a beautiful place.
Yeah.
And I had done it in 2014.
Uh,
Vince Vaughn,
wild west,
he has a comedy festival there.
I don't know if you've done it yet,
but that's where I did it.
But did the ryman there for the same
reason?
Yeah.
So I went out there and I was like,
you know,
everyone was like,
I don't know,
it's the first place they did the Grand
Ole opry.
I was,
you know,
Hank Williams,
whatever.
And you're like,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
Now the theater and you walk in,
you're like,
oh wait a minute.
This had just had that magic in it and I
was went out and I had this great set
and that's just,
you know,
you just stick it in the card catalog
going.
All right,
next time I have A.
I was like,
I just burned all this material so I got
to write a whole new hour and come back
here.
And so next time,
um,
you know,
I go to shoot something.
I think there was about a month before I
did the Tabernacle for my one previous
to that,
so I already knew which was cool before
I wrote my next hour where I was going
to shoot it.
So are you on a two year schedule?
You think that that's the way to do it?
Roughly two years.
But I have like a,
like a vibe of when like this one was
overcooked and just because I got real
busy with F is for family.
I would have liked to have taped it like
about six months earlier,
but it made it a,
I think it,
it made it better or whatever,
but I would have just as far as,
you know what I mean,
it's,
it's kind of like in this business,
there's that thing,
you don't want to be overexposed,
but then you don't want to wait too
long,
so you got to try to.
And then that's also not like a Oh so
and so successful and he waits x amount
of time.
So I'm going to do the exact thing.
It's really,
um,
it's really like whatever you're trying
to do.
So it's Kinda different for different
people.
Like those youtube stars,
like their thing is all about just
constantly putting out stuff where I
think the road that I'm on is,
you know,
like right now I'm out there promoting
this shit and then once it comes out and
everybody's seeing it and they're liking
it and then I'm done promoting it,
then I just sort of disappeared until F
is for family comes out.
Um,
I'm kind of a big believer in that.
Have you know,
be out there when you got something
that's going on.
Don't just do shit to do shit.
I call that like extra TV.
Hey,
he's just here to be here and now he's
over there.
There's that guy again.
Then I,
because I find myself,
people that I'm fans of starting to hate
people going like,
you fucking get away from this fucking
guy.
Then I'm thinking like,
do I actually hate this person or I
don't know what it is,
but there's definitely a tipping point.
You know?
It was real smart about that.
Daniel Tosh,
he doesn't do shit.
He doesn't do a fucking thing.
He sells out everywhere he goes.
He's got millions of dollars,
so he's like,
I don't,
I don't need to do shit.
I'm overexposed as it is.
My shows on constantly.
I'm not doing nothing.
He won't do interviews.
Doesn't do podcasts.
Yeah.
Adam Sandler's.
Another guy.
Yeah.
Adam Sandler doesn't do.
I don't.
I'm trying to think.
The last time I saw him promote a movie
and yet I see all of his movies and then
I just hear through the Grapevine,
oh,
he signed some big thing with Netflix.
All his movies are going to be over
there.
I was like,
all right.
I guess I'm watching them over there and
I've always just sort of like.
And it wasn't until um,
I talked to somebody like,
yeah,
he doesn't do any press good for his
sick.
Basically.
I might be wrong,
but from what I heard for he does very
little if he does any.
Yeah,
no,
he's smart and he's got his core
audience,
you know?
Uh,
I watched,
uh,
Jack and Jill with my kids with my six
year old and my eight year old.
It is fucking hilarious when you watch,
when you watch a really silly movie with
a six year old and an eight year old and
they're literally fallen off the couch
laughing.
That's awesome.
And you realize like,
oh,
he's making movies for little kids.
Like people who get mad at it,
you know,
like all those movies are stupid dude.
Not if you're six,
you're six.
They're fucking awesome.
What if you just getting a stupid move?
That's what I like.
I don't want to fucking think every time
I go see him,
but sometimes they just want somebody to
make me laugh.
I liked,
uh,
the XO had one.
I loved that movie.
Yeah.
When was coming up with hilarious dude.
I remember when I was living with Bobby
Kelly,
we watched waterboy by Bobby Boucher.
We watched that thing like fucking 900
times.
Like it was kind of like a Goto,
you know,
if we didn't have spots,
you try to kill a day.
Just we had the little vhs thing.
We,
I probably saw that movie at least 30,
40 times.
Yeah.
And Happy Gilmore.
I saw happy Gilmore at least 10 times.
That's a fucking great.
I forget the name of the last one when
he did with spade.
When he was a.
He worked at the bank and the
supermarket.
Did you watch that one?
That was his first Netflix one that came
out like last year.
None.
Didn't see it.
My short term memory's shot,
but that was,
that was a funny one to know.
His movies are,
they're always consistently that way,
you know,
that Kinda that kind of movie.
No,
and I liked it there.
Unapologetically silly.
No,
because uh,
you know,
he's a guy that gets a lot of shit and
he just doesn't give a shit.
Like,
all right.
You didn't like this one is another one
that made a zillion dollars.
Yeah.
Avoid the press.
Find your core audience to what you got
to do.
Yeah.
I like that.
What you're doing.
Like they're like,
that's sort of schedule.
I feel like that's kind of the same
amount of time that I do around a year
and a half.
I started thinking this thing's about
don,
you know,
and uh,
a year.
And I feel like wow,
I could kind of pull it off,
but not really.
You're not smarter than you take it out
of the oven too soon.
Then there's just like that,
you know,
was still a little mushy.
That's just like,
you know,
I,
yeah,
you go out there and you kick the shit
out of him every couple of years.
Hopefully.
Hopefully they like it and then they'll
come see you again on your next tour.
Yeah.
And,
and that's all you owe them and that's
all they owe you.
It's just like,
I saw you last one.
You're still in my wheelhouse of people.
I'm going to go see,
but the second you fuck up,
I'm not going to go see you when you
can't ask.
You can't ask fans to do any more than
that.
No.
What about the other stuff I did that
didn't suck.
It's like,
yeah,
but your last thing sucked in this two
minute.
Too much unbelievable stuff being put
out.
So you've got to kind of try and keep
up.
Yeah.
Artist should fear had a real good point
about that too.
He said that at one point in time
comedians used to have a.
They used to do a special and it was
like the best special,
like an hbo special and then they would
slide off.
They would all slide off every one of
them,
like kinnisons the worst,
like Kennison.
You watched kinisons first special and
then you watch it,
like listen to louder than hell that
that cassette.
And watch this first HBO special fucking
genius,
just balls out and if you don't get it,
I understand because it's not 1986
anymore,
but if you were in 1986 and you saw that
you would have been blown away,
you would have been like in the presence
of greatness.
Like,
oh,
he's on my mount rushmore.
That got me too.
Me Too.
But then the stuff after that was dog
shit.
It got worse and worse and worse as far
as I could just.
I mean,
I never met the guy,
but just as far as watching him as a
fan,
he kind of seemed like he stepped in
every single pitfall of being,
uh,
of getting some fame.
Yup.
Everything like not trying as hard coke
girls showing up late to shit,
hanging out with Bon Jovi.
Getting a bad reputation.
A Motley crew.
It wasn't Bon Jovi to you?
Yeah.
It was one of his early specials,
like Bon Jovi was on the beginning of
his special.
I just remember he drove motley crew to
the whiskey for the kickstart.
My heart video.
Oh,
that's right.
The eighties though.
That's a great video.
That fucking kickstart my heart still to
this day.
When that comes out at the gym,
I get fired up.
Oh,
it's a great song to crave fucking
dialogue in the beginning is brutal
though.
It goes,
here we are.
It gets something like this is where it
all began and and the guy goes and then
some of the cargoes.
Yeah.
Then he goes home,
sweet home,
and then they all go,
yeah.
Oh God.
Pull that up.
Give you some volume to it in the
eighties.
Those.
Yeah,
but Tommy Lee's drums in this.
A fucking amazing.
Wow.
Forget how long these guys have been
around.
How long
Tommy Lee's been around?
How has it?
How were his arms not fallen off?
Give her.
Give me a little volume on that.
Jamie.
I want to hear this.
Fuck yeah.
This is the best treadmill song of all
time.
If you're on the treadmill,
it's a fucking great song for working
out,
man.
I think this is the best song ever.
Did you really?
Oh Wow.
You were explaining to me something
before the podcast started.
I wanted you to talk about it on the
podcast because you were talking about
drum technique and you had like a slow
motion video of how you do it and you're
kind of letting the stick do lot of the
work.
Yeah.
I got this great teacher,
a Davy lottery played with everybody
from a Mars Volta to like Miley Cyrus.
So whatever your Gig is like total
progressive,
crazy.
I can't even.
Some of the music he's played.
I got to know where one is and then he
can also just do the straight pop tour
or whatever.
But um,
his technique is incredible.
It's the first time I saw him play.
He's got this drum camp.
I should,
I should show it to you.
It literally,
I'm looking at it and you know,
laymen's eyes.
I was like,
how is this guy's arms not falling off?
But his technique,
you know,
as I've gone and taken lessons for well
over a year with them,
now I can watch it on a different level
as far as like,
his technique is sick so he's not
fucking his arms up and everything.
He's moving his arms,
given people a show,
but like it's,
it's,
it's hard to explain like,
um,
first of all,
I'm not a professional drummer,
but it's also hard to explain like over
a podcast,
but like,
he's like,
yeah,
it's,
it's letting the stick do the work and
he kind of equated it to like,
if you'd like dribbling a ball or
something like that,
or maybe it was somebody else.
If you dribble a basketball to every
time it comes up to your hand,
once you get it going,
you're not slamming it back down to the
floor.
You just controlling the rebound.
It's something sorted to do.
There it is.
This is the one that if you play a,
you could turn up the volume.
I'm just,
this is just going to bore the shit out
of people with.
No,
no it's not.
You see it as hands.
How loose his hands are seen when he
just opens his hand like that.
He's getting,
you know,
this guy's a fucking animal,
man.
You Love Drumming,
Huh?
You're,
you're fucking really deep into this
shit.
It's literally a tried therapy.
I tried talking to people in Shit and
it's just like,
yeah,
I only get so far,
but like that stuff like just totally
clears my head and I like it because
it's like comedy where there's somewhere
to go with it and it's endless.
There's really no end to how good you
can come as a comic if you keep pushing
yourself with this little skill sets
that you're,
you know,
they're kind of weak and you can just
keep making,
you know,
working on drawings the same way.
So it's that going for the next thing
that has me just present trying to work
it out and I just forget about
everything else.
And um,
you know,
I even got a kid now.
My wife's still lets me go play for an
hour day because she knows it's good for
us.
So that's like,
it's like a meditation on top of a
little bit of a workout too because
you're throwing your arms around.
Oh yeah.
Threaded.
It's like you do look at guys like
Travis Barker and Tommy Lee,
those guys have Jack Veins.
They're all shredded.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
Well that part of that I think is also
like if you just sort of struggle,
there's also something too,
and that's,
I'm not talking about anybody you just
mentioned,
but there is something,
something about if you do heroin in your
twenties,
you're kinda like shredded for life.
I don't know what it is.
Iggy pop.
I don't know if he did.
He did hard drugs.
He definitely does.
Guys are like these guys.
It just shredded.
It's very rare that after you come out
of that,
you know,
Keith Richards,
all of those guys that just Keith
Richards is like,
you could pick that guy up with two
fucking fingers and he's.
Yeah,
he's all like,
yeah.
It's like he did pull out.
He's not just shot heroin for like
three years.
He still shredded his skin.
Skin is giving up,
losing the elasticity,
but he's still,
he's still a shredded.
Yeah,
he's.
His body is very odd.
I saw him,
I saw him.
In a way.
You're looking at him now and he's like
70.
I saw him with Queens of the stone age
backing them up.
I saw my downtown La how long ago?
Like fuck it,
about a year ago,
this is what I loved about the guy.
He went out there and in and like one
song and he had his fucking shirt off,
just didn't give a shit.
He's the crusher of music.
Yeah.
And that's why.
That's why I like,
you know,
when they give Madonna's shit for torque
and it 58,
it's like,
who gives a fuck?
I mean there is something,
you know,
there is like,
there is something to be said about a,
it's all how you do it.
He did it.
I felt like he didn't give a fuck.
But if it kind of doing is this
desperate thing still trying to be like
good luck and then it gets a little,
uh,
I guess it gets a little cheesy.
The Madonna thing,
it's not working.
It's the shit that she says with the
torquing,
you know,
like,
uh,
I'll,
I'll suck everyone's dick who doesn't
vote for trump.
Like that kind of stuff.
Like really well,
she's been able to hang around for
fucking 40 years doing it.
I didn't know,
but it's just like,
don't do that anymore.
What if a tooth falls out?
What if you're blowing somebody and it
just goes wrong?
She just,
he's 70 years old or so.
She doesn't.
She's 85 years old.
She's 128,
58.
He's 10 years older than me.
She's in better shape than I'll ever be
in.
She seems a lot older than that.
I mean when we were kids,
she was already a grown woman.
What she broke,
she was like 25.
I think she made a quick.
I remember when I was in high school,
I've told this story before,
but when I was like 16 and I was in love
with her and I found out she was 27 and
I was like,
that pitches old Jesus Christ.
I thought 27 and then curb at 16.
I didn't even hit him.
I know it just was a retarded.
I was 16.
I didn't know anybody,
but I just remembered hearing she was in
her late twenties to over look at her
house when she was kind of Chubby to do
a.
I did think 27 though when I was a kid,
like when I would see a 27 year old guy.
I think that's a man.
He's got it figured out.
He's on his own,
you know,
none of this bullshit I'm going through
is all sorted out his fucking head.
I used to think that I had a little bit
about that 48 and I'm just going to be
49 this year and I'm just like still
figuring shit out.
I had a whole bit about.
Remember when you were a kid and you
thought they were real grownups like
you.
You didn't know you were confused.
He get yelled at,
he gets sent to your room.
You're like,
one day I'm going to be a grown up and
everything's gonna make sense?
And then one day you're in line at the
supermarket and someone goes,
paper or plastic,
Sir sir,
sir,
my grownup.
Fuck this is it.
Then you realize there's no grownups
too.
It's just a bunch of babies you got
and they're all pretending and they look
like they're grown up to you because
you're on the outside.
But once you become one of them,
you realize there is no up.
Oops,
this,
there's some out there.
This,
uh,
men and women out there.
I'm not one of them.
Have you met one?
Yeah,
like who named one?
Uh,
I've met a few as far as like in this
business as far as like,
people just like a,
I would say anybody who was,
they have like this super successful in
this business,
but then they just go home.
You know what I mean?
You just go home.
Like that's an adult,
right?
You know,
they fucking blushing,
you know,
if there is an after party,
they make their appearance,
they have a little seltzer water and
they're gone and they get eight hours
sleep that cock.
They're talking to their wife and their
kids like,
to me those,
those are adults to do what I do is,
you know,
to still go out and fucking have a
couple of whiskeys and wake up a little
hung over going,
Oh God,
what did I do that for the 9000000th
time in my life?
Like I.
Yeah,
I'm not an adult.
Yeah.
But I don't feel.
I don't think there's anyone like that.
That's a comic.
I don't know anybody that's really funny
that has it all totally together.
I've never met one ever name one.
They don't exist.
Funny.
Yeah,
they don't exist.
They're all fucked up a little bit.
Just a little.
I mean keeping it together,
like paying your taxes,
showing up on time,
all that good stuff,
right.
Adult like,
but all,
every,
every one of us is one.
No,
it's not bad,
but every one of us has one shitty
decision from a disaster.
Every one of us at any point in time
when I watched people,
uh,
I dunno when they watched him fuck up
their lives.
Like there's always a.
The first feeling I have is panic.
When I see it.
I'm like,
Oh God.
Imagine what they're thinking.
Right.
You imagine yourself in their position.
What if I did that?
Yeah.
Like when you see someone pulled over
for drunk driving,
like,
fuck.
Oh No.
The whole fucking thing.
Giving you money to the wrong people.
They mismanagement.
Oh,
broke.
Becoming a fucking Aleke.
I just read something about banging the.
Made all the bag in the major good.
One maid or the nanny.
You can't have a maid or a nanny
in your life.
Well,
if you do,
they have to be disgusting.
That's like the unathletic bang.
His nanny.
He did.
Right.
That was never confirmed.
That was never confessed.
She confirmed it.
Yeah,
but what does that mean?
She needs a book deal.
She got fired.
Who knows?
Unless he came out and said,
I never fucked her and he never did
this.
Dude.
You're going to do that to them.
I'm not a big fan of his.
You know how you didn't like the town?
No,
I didn't like him.
He went on the Bill Maher show cutting
this ridiculous argument with Sam Harris
and I realized what what he's all about.
I was like,
Oh,
you're one of those guys who's like
Colin?
Sam Harris,
racist,
because he was talking about the problem
with ideologies and religions and the
tenants of Islam and he started yelling
at him,
calling him a racist and didn't really
understand that.
Sam Harris is actually a scholar,
knows a lot about religion.
Just way over his head and looked really
stupid.
So the only difference between me and
him as he did that on TV and I do it
over the phone with friends.
The only difference is you're funny,
you're funny if you did it,
you have self deprecating humor.
You would have,
you know,
like the fuck am I talking about?
Talk to the guy at the gas station.
And I just stopped at right before I got
here.
When I found out they didn't take credit
cards.
What happened?
It just didn't take,
you know,
I was mad at him.
Uh,
I,
I was a content.
Really?
Yeah.
Because what it was was I was getting up
against being here by 11 and I got to
get home to take my wife out of the
house because she's going nuts staying
in the house with the kids.
So I got that thing and I got assigned
this other fucking,
you know,
life insurance,
I got to do all this adult shit and I'm
thinking I got this little window to get
gas and I show up in this fucking
industrial park.
There's no gas station.
I finally going all the way down and the
whole time it was like,
it's thrifty and I'm thinking like,
isn't that a fucking car rental place?
So I pull in and I stick to credit
rights.
I stuck in and I'm going,
this is too easy because I know I have
the exact amount of time to get her
right on time.
And of course it's just like,
is this debit?
I'm like,
ah,
you can't.
I'm like,
no.
And they go,
go in and see the,
uh,
the guy behind the register.
I'm like,
yeah,
I tried to use my credit card.
And he goes,
oh,
we don't,
we don't take credit cards here.
And I go,
why?
He goes,
I'll just take debit card.
I just kept saying why two year old and
he finally just goes cheaper.
And I was like,
ah,
that's a good,
that's a good excuse.
And it gave him like 60 bucks and only
ended up being like 30 nights that I had
to go back and get my change and he's
looking at me like,
say a fucking idiot.
It would have cost you like 15 more.
So I do that all the time.
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of those fucking debit
card.
Only ones.
That's stupid.
Lynette,
you never use your debit card,
your credit card anyway.
What happened?
Because that's your money.
So if somebody takes that and then
cleans you out,
that's your shit.
If somebody swipes your credit card
number,
that's their money.
So then they call you up and they just
go,
hey joe,
did you buy a ham hock and fucking
Vancouver had a strip club?
Uh,
well I know I didn't go.
Good luck with that.
You've given me every piece of the
fucking elk except that
I've got some ham hock for you.
Some,
some bone he can chop up and make
marijuana.
So I got to,
I got a buddy of mine who's a lawyer who
prosecutes identity theft,
which a lot of lawyers don't want to do
because it's unbelievably tedious.
And they,
when they call up,
a lot of times they call her up the
credit card companies to,
uh,
to fight for their case.
They still have to go through that maze.
If you'd like to do this,
press one if you'd like to do that,
press two,
you know,
and they're trying to help them out.
So.
But that was one thing that I remembered
at all things he told me not to do it
because don't ever use your debit card
because if they get that and they clean
you out,
that's your fucking mind,
you know,
and then all of a sudden you get a
mortgage coming up and then you're late
and you're like,
no,
but somebody took my money and blah blah
blah blah blah.
It's your credit card.
They have to deal with it.
I had it
attempt recently and uh,
I'm,
I'm thinking,
I'm wondering whether or not it's
because I switched over to windows
because,
you know,
I had this windows computer now,
like I get pissed off at Mac.
People got mad at us clearing her throat
and I just cleared my throat again.
Um,
I switched over to this windows computer
because I get mad.
These MACs,
they,
they switched over all the ports and now
you have this Usb c and you have to get
an adapter if you want to use all your
other shit to it.
And it's like you've got Rosetta Stone
French,
right?
I can't,
there's no place to stick the fucking.
Yeah,
you have to get an adapter.
You saw.
I was like,
what the fuck?
How about the iphone seven with the
little fucking biblical code lightning
thing?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you can get a splitter.
Would that,
where it goes with a,
you can use a regular headphone Jack,
but it's all extra money,
extra money and then you fucking lose
them.
I think the idea is that eventually
there's going to be some peripherals
that are more powerful and they don't
work on the existing ports,
but you know,
like I got this,
uh,
this Lenovo thinkpad and I love it and
this is the second one that I got
because it's got everything.
It's got an Ethernet port,
it's got htmi,
it's got all this shit.
It's tiny.
The battery life is fucking forever.
It's got this fat battery in the bottom.
But for the first time in a long time,
somebody tried to steal my identity and
I'm like,
Geez,
I wonder if it's has to do with that.
I wonder if it's a windows thing.
Does that make sense?
Not really.
Could be.
Could be something else.
I don't know.
But uh,
it sneaky.
But at least when I have a business
management company,
they contact me.
They put a stop to it right away.
Oh,
that's cool.
But it's a,
it's disconcerting that your shit's out
there,
you know,
that someone's trying to find your
social security number and attached to
your credit card and buy something.
I've had an happening at the gas
stations where they put that fake
scanner on.
They put a fake scanner over the
scanner.
So as you scan through and you're even
allowed,
you even are using it like you're using
your credit card,
you're buying gas,
but you gave them your credit card
information.
Yeah,
I,
two times credit cards that's happening
at gas station restaurants are another
big double swipe thing.
Restaurants.
Well that's people that work there.
Scumbags.
You gotta go,
you gotta go cash as much as you can.
I know,
right?
Isn't that crazy?
This never happened.
You don't know me.
I know a guy.
He's dead now,
but he was one of the first credit card
thieves.
His name was international sale.
That's what we used to call them because
uh,
when he got arrested,
that's what the,
that was what his nickname was,
was international south because this
isn't like the seventies and the
eighties.
When credit cards first came out,
he would get those,
uh,
those carbon slips from restaurants and
they would make up new credit cards and
then sell them to criminals and he would
just get bags and bags of cash from it.
And this guy was gambling who go to the
pool hall that I went to and just,
he was like the most perpetual loser
you've ever seen in your life.
Like he could not win.
It was a psychological and an Oscar
winning movie.
Yeah.
This guy's life.
Well,
in a way it probably should be.
I mean,
he was a,
he was a trip.
So how did he,
how did he end up dying cancer bad,
but colon cancer,
it was a real,
it was real bad.
And a buddy of mine's Hollywood would
switch up the script just to calm and go
off a bridge like Thelma and Louise.
He,
um,
that's what happened to me the other
night when I was onstage and I was
joking about men going to the moon and
somebody yelled out,
go see hidden figures.
And I was like,
yeah,
because that's a history book.
Like I just saw how people.
I'm not saying those obviously is women
existed,
but like did.
Then now they're going to do the
overcorrection where it was like these
three women are there.
It's just like every time that you see a
picture of like NASA,
you'll see like a thousand,
like 100 worker bees.
Nobody knows their fucking names.
It's like we got there because of all of
those people.
But it's just like a second when a team
wins a championship.
Like if they weren't at the Patriots
win,
it's going to be all about Tom Brady.
You know,
no one's gonna know the fucking
offensive line's name and if,
and if,
if,
uh,
if the Falcons win,
it's going to be about,
you know,
I don't know.
Julio Jones are Matt Ryan.
You know,
these guys would know this.
Tom Brady's got some wacky diet.
There was some article about Tom Brady's
diet being bullshit.
Do you know about Tom Brady's diet?
It's got some crazy diet.
No,
I don't get into people's personal
lives.
I watched the game now,
but I don't,
I wouldn't if they only pay like Tom
Brady talks about is what,
you know,
beans and fucking rice.
No,
fuck no,
I just want to watch the game.
I don't watch pre pregame,
postgame.
I don't need you to break it down for
me.
I watched it,
you know,
I,
I like there's certain people that if
they were to break it down,
it's the same thing with like what you
do.
There's certain things like the reason
why I like you're commentating was I
learned about like the leg kicks and was
like,
you always hammer that home.
How much set just chops the other guy
down,
aside from the fact is,
you know,
I've been kicked in the Shin,
everybody has an getting a Charlie horse
and I just don't understand like,
like that one that I'm conor mcgregor
had against.
Uh,
uh,
what's his face there?
Uh,
or tease.
Now notice I'm the worst with the names.
It's farther than the second time.
The Gas Diaz Diaz when just watching him
repeatedly kick him in the leg.
And then in the end he mcgregor leaves
on crutches.
It's just like a foot.
Yeah.
Like how much is your adrenaline going,
going like crazy.
Then you feel a thing?
Yeah.
That you can just keep kicking somebody
in their leg,
hitting the bone with the top bone of
your or whatever he was in your parcels.
Whatever the hell it is.
And um,
and just keep it.
I could just picture myself kicking.
The guy wants going.
Ah,
just grabbing it and hopping up and
down.
Like the guy on family guy here most of
the time.
Feel it while it's happening.
I'm broken.
I broke my Shin,
I broke my foot,
broke both feet,
kick elbows,
elbows are a way that a lot of times
guys break it because guys will cover up
and your foot like your instep of
slamming to the elbow.
Your instep always loses,
always shins out.
Now when she gets wears off and you
realize broken your instep,
kicking someone as hard as you can in
their elbow.
What?
What is that pain like?
Agony.
Just throbbing.
Your foot swells up to like the size of
your thigh.
It just gets,
becomes as big balloon of black and blue
and that's disgusting.
You know?
It's funny,
after watching my wife go through labor
and everything,
I said the only men that could actually
relate would be people who do that for a
fucking living.
Like people will fight.
They couldn't even relate it.
It's worse than that.
That's genitals,
genitals.
It's coming out of your vagina.
It's crazy.
No,
I got a whole new level of respect for
my wife.
I was just like,
oh.
She told me the funniest fucking thing
when she went into like pre labor,
you know,
and I was just going.
I was,
you know,
telling her to breathe and I was running
to get the stuff,
you know,
I was pretty prepared and there was some
code or something like that as I was
like,
you know,
neo,
where did you leave the blah,
blah,
blah.
She goes,
when you said that to me,
she goes,
I was almost ready to black out with the
pain.
And she goes,
I,
I had this thought if he asked me one
more time with that code is I'm going to
push this baby out and fucking throw it
out.
My wife is hilarious.
Um,
she's funny on your podcast to very
funny.
He's funnier than a lot of comedians.
I know.
She's fucking hilarious.
And uh,
but she has this.
What I love about it,
she's got this spirit man.
She's just really like,
when I met her man,
like I had never met anybody,
like very few people I've met in my life
to have like an energy.
We just like,
wow.
I'm like,
I want to be around that.
Like she just had this amazing,
uh,
like really,
like she just throws herself into shit.
And I was really kind of,
uh,
you know,
I was more like garden and all of that,
so it was sort of the perfect kind of
balance.
But every time I've,
I think I've seen the end of,
of that energy,
like she does something else.
So yeah,
it was pretty,
pretty amazing.
So that's good.
Great relationship then you're both
growing,
you know,
she's growing in your.
Oh yeah,
no dude,
she's hit me with some fucking classic
lines and one time she was calling her
out on some shit she was doing and I
just took it like a little too far.
I should've stopped like probably five
minutes early and I was still going,
I go,
you fucking blah blah blah,
blah blah.
And you do this.
And I was in the car and right as I
stuff.
She goes,
yeah,
well,
you know,
pony righty.
That my friend and we both just burst
out laughing and that was just like the
end of the fight.
So she has that ability.
Um,
we're in the past,
you know,
I would date people either they were too
nice,
so they couldn't handle how fucked up I
was or the worst,
they would just as fucked up as I was
in.
It was totally toxic.
So she's just sorta like grounded.
Yeah,
that's,
that's so important when you're dating
somebody or married somebody or
whatever,
they have to compliment you and you have
to compliment them some sort of a way.
You can't be the exactly the same.
And who you are is different when you're
with different people,
you know,
if you're with a person like that who
can crack a joke in the middle of the
heat of everything,
you'd be become a different person.
They become a different person.
Yeah.
But if she's with somebody who doesn't
appreciate that,
you know,
it's just like you become,
like you're not just an individual,
you're an individual who relates to
other people and you become someone
different when you relate to those
people.
Yeah.
Uh,
it took me forever to realize that
process.
It was,
how can I can't break up with this
person?
That's how I figured out I was in love.
Well,
that's a good one too though.
Yeah,
no.
Every time I pictured breaking up with
her,
I kept picturing her walking away and
then me going like,
no,
no.
Then after denying that,
that was love for a good fucking eight
years.
I was just like,
yeah,
I guess.
I guess I have found the one doesn't
abused word love is way too many people
throwing that word around like a beach
ball at a concert.
It's just to abused all of that shit and
then like all of that stuff that people
say that when you first see a kid,
like they fill your head up on what the
fuck you supposed to feel?
I was talking about this on a thick on
kimball,
like w what I saw my kid for the first
time.
I was like,
afraid.
Like I was like,
I didn't have that.
Just start crying.
I was just like,
hey.
And I sorta just put my finger down,
let it hold.
And when they left me alone with the
first time,
like the magnitude of it was,
was,
was definitely huge.
But I didn't feel that whole.
Like,
you know,
the second I saw my kid,
I knew my life had changed,
but I didn't feel that for like 12
hours.
It wasn't until the next.
But I think it was my head was so filled
up on what I was supposed.
I was like having an outer body
experience and it wasn't until,
you know,
the next morning my wife was playing
like stevie wonder,
you know,
what I mean,
some chill music and stuff.
And I was just sitting with her and it
just sort of,
you know,
and you know,
baby baby sneezes or something like that
and he just.
And it just fucking hits Ya.
Yeah.
Um,
but even then I never had like that
blubbering moment.
To me it was kind of scary too and kind
of psychedelic because when,
uh,
when my daughter was born,
my eight year old was born.
There was a moment what I was thinking,
how many babies are being born
simultaneously right now all over the
world.
And if you could look at it on a screen,
it would be a swarm of humanity,
just just heads popping out of pussies.
It's just,
if you could see every baby coming out
right now and then,
and then our thought at the same time,
I thought about this baby becoming an
old lady and dying.
And I thought like how many old people
are dying simultaneously at the same
time right now?
Yeah.
See,
I think it's actually this way that
because every,
the,
the hacky thing is you're supposed to
say the second I saw my kid I burst out
crying and blah blah blah blah blah.
And then so then it becomes like,
if you don't do that,
you're not going to be a good dad.
You don't care.
And all of that type of stuff.
But I just think that that kind of
became like the Hacky,
um,
default thing.
And then I also,
this is all just theories of course,
and I'm not going to research any of
this,
but I think parents try to outdo each
other with their stories about what the
fuck they felt.
And it's just because like,
they're really,
they're really like,
they're not saying people,
most parents know and I've learned to
kind of already be like,
they'll just sit down next to you,
like your forrest gump and they'll just
sit down and just start talking to you.
So you just said,
you kid all right.
When the switch got to watch out for,
you know,
and I remember my kid and blah blah blah
blah.
It's like airplane.
You know what I mean?
With a fucking person.
He talks to them when you want to kill
yourself,
just wait until you start going to
school.
Then you gotTa,
you gotTa hang out with these parents
all the time because your kids become
friends with their kids and then you
become friends with these people that
you would never be fucking friends with.
This is what I do is I just looked
straight ahead and I don't look at him,
I don't respond to what they're saying.
And then they just solely talk quieter
and they gradually leave.
You're going to have to go to dinner
with them.
Your wife's going to be friends with
some lady.
You're going to go on a double date.
Okay,
fine.
You're going to go.
This is one guy now he he talks and he
doesn't look at you.
He tells me these fucking stupid stories
about his kid and the basketball team
and he looks at you for a second.
So,
so Adam is in his basketball team and
they start looking down.
He's like,
did the coach won't put them in the
game?
What I'm saying like if he gets a good
player could play.
I come in,
I can put them in the game and he's
fucking rambling.
Rambling with no regard whatsoever for
your attention span.
The entertainment value of what he's
saying.
He's just the underlying insecurity of
not being able to look at you.
Oh,
he's so in self-involved.
He's self involved is doing some weird
thing with his hands were just like
click talking with his hands and I'm
going Jesus Christ.
Like literally like someone's fantasize
about doing tool,
not just running,
just running away.
I don't want to hurt him.
The guy's hurt by life.
He's so damaged by live.
I don't want to do anything to him.
I just wanna get the fuck away.
I always picture those people and I have
a giant roll of duct tape.
I just put it on.
It's like a cartoon level speed.
No,
it's cartoon level.
I just put it on their mouth and I go
and the last one it comes up and over
their head and then it hangs down.
The whole rest of the tape is hanging
down over there awkwardly and then I
just go back to eating or whatever and
they just sit there and slowly have to
take it off.
It is some brutal fucking people.
It's,
you know,
there's a bunch of weird people that
you,
you know,
you get closer to them and closer to
them and you find out about their life.
Yeah.
But you know what?
All those people,
I want to do that too.
I'm sure they're talking about me,
so for sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure they talked about me too.
That's just how it seemed like he was in
a bad mood now all the time.
Yeah.
This is friend of Ron White,
who's a friend of mine who uh,
the first time we met him he was like,
ah,
I don't know.
And Ron's like,
I'm telling you,
he's a good guy.
Like he's a dad too,
and we're all buddies together now,
but he's like,
I don't know,
I just,
I'm guarded.
I've been beaten down by some of these
fucking basketball stories.
It's these assholes will tell you I had
my kid,
he's a good player player.
Did you want to put them in the game?
Just you think of things that you would
torture somebody talking about and you
like,
I would never do this to you.
Why are you doing this to me?
You're not even thinking about verbal
water
like in your own
little Guantanamo.
That's a great way to describe me.
Like when is the desert trade coming?
So I could say I don't need dessert.
That's part of the problem with hanging
around with comedians too.
So when they say something like,
for a good percentage of it,
it's funny.
It doesn't have to be funny all the
time,
but a good percentage when you talking
to people that aren't funny at all and
it never comes.
He likes surely there's something funny
coming.
Eventually nothing,
never,
never something compelling.
Nothing,
not a goddamn thing.
Just coach and that's when I start
thinking like those duct tape fantasies
and then I start making myself laugh and
I have to pretend like I'm drinking and
then they get all weirded out because
they see some weird look on my face and
it just fucking.
It just goes south.
Yeah,
I'd usually breathe.
I take these breathing exercises.
I do the Wim Hoff method where I took
all my breath in and I let like 15,
20 percent.
Now.
There's no way you do that across from a
personal.
I guess if he's not looking at you,
he doesn't see it.
Yeah,
I do.
I do like to watch ready.
Any noise just got shot and you're
waiting for the ambulance when you're
doing good.
Just trying to stay.
Stay consciously put together,
try to stay present.
I try to meditate in the face of
overwhelming retarded conversation.
Just trying to detach myself from
whatever they're saying,
find a,
find a happy place,
find a peaceful spot.
Do you ever get raw?
You know what Rolfing is?
It's a form of like deep,
deep tissue massage,
brutally painful shit.
Brutally painful.
Uh,
I get robbed and I,
this guy,
uh,
that does it.
He's fucking rough and he knows how to
do it.
Hey,
this guy's rough target.
He,
uh,
he has a metal bar.
I mean,
it really,
it seems like a torture device.
It looks like a chisel,
like a fat wide Chisel and it has like a
thin layer of like rubber over it.
And he takes this metal bar that has
like a,
a handle,
like a sword.
He's wearing a mask at this point.
I'm naked unfortunately.
And uh,
he's
digging this fucking thing into my back.
I mean digging it in like all of his
weight and he's like pop popping over
the scar tissue.
And uh,
I,
I have to go deep into my mind when he's
doing it.
I just go,
just go deeper and deep.
My eyes are closed,
my faces in that thing.
And then when you get a massage and that
stuff,
you could see my face and bill.
I like pushed and smushed into the
little massage chair thing or massage
table thing
they're going to do.
When that red bull jumped,
buddy is a world champion at that shit.
He's.
He's traveled more in that flying
squirrel suit.
He's traveled to further distances than
anything.
Do that red bull jumped that fucking guy
was.
I think it was like he was just fall.
He was just falling like a stone from
space over here.
How about the guy that fell into a net?
Did you see that one?
I just did the comment.
I totally derailed.
You know,
it's okay.
I,
I find my happy space while this guy's
doing this and I have to do that.
I literally,
I think I'm going,
I go deeper and deeper in my mind to
ignore the pain because the pain is so
intense.
Talk Basketball Guy is.
If I already told my wife that he did it
and it annoyed me and then what I would
do is I would just be egging him on
going like,
so why?
Why doesn't he play him and just and
just keep going and then she would start
kicking me under the table because she
would start laughing and then I would
have to turn what he was doing into a
show.
That's the only way to do it or else I'm
just going to say.
I would probably,
if I actually dealt with the emotion of
those kinds of moments,
I would probably start crying.
I would probably just break down and be
like,
fucking doing this.
Well,
I would.
I just feel like I have to talk to the
guy.
I feel like I wish I could die.
Get them high on ecstasy and talk to
them.
Just get them to completely remove all
of his insecurities and fears and it'd
be like,
man,
when you talk to people,
you got to be thinking that they're
listening to you.
I can great suggestion for.
If you have to keep going out with a
couple like that,
you gotta get the corner booth so then
you're not directly across from each
other,
so you don't have to look at him.
You can just.
You can just sit there in your
meditation nodding and he's not going to
be looking at USC and it's peripheral as
if you're actively listening and you can
be looking.
It doesn't matter what this guy,
he clarion we'll get you.
I think he's a little on the spectrum or
something going on there.
There's,
if it bleeds,
we can kill.
It is a detachment detachment to way he
communicates where it just,
it's uh,
seems like socially he's not present is
very odd.
Very odd method of communication.
Yup.
I hear Ya.
I know somebody like that.
You can't talk to the guy and like you'd
want,
I'd want to like tell them like,
you know,
again,
you have this thing but you gotta it's
gotTa be fun for the other person here.
Like there's got to be something there
and you know,
we've all done something like that.
We've all said something someone didn't
want to listen to for sure.
Not Me.
Oh No.
I walk in wearing a scarf scarf and
those snoopy aviator goggles.
That's right.
Everybody wants to hear my bullshit.
So there was that guy that jumped,
right?
He jumped somewhere and he fell into a
net.
He didn't even have a parachute.
They have like a gigantic net somewhere,
right?
Wasn't that what it was?
How far did he fall?
Twenty 5,000
feet.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this guy.
So he skydiving 25,000
feet and he doesn't have a parachute and
he's doing tricks.
What the fuck kind of impact must have
been like,
oh Jesus,
look it up.
And at the very last minute he has to
turn around.
So he's steering himself and at the very
last minute,
Jesus,
what kind of fear?
The very last minute he has to turn.
Look at that.
Holy Shit.
That's insane.
I mean,
how fast is he going at that point?
So now he's not moving.
Now he's crying because he can't believe
he got away with it and he doesn't know
why the fuck he did it.
I know why he did is he,
you know what I want to hear?
I want to hear his opening line to a
woman in a bar.
I bet it's the worst thing,
like literally to compensate rather than
just,
you know,
getting a book.
Hey baby,
but she signed,
he's got to do this shit and then talk
about it loudly in the vicinity of
women.
Luke aikens is his name.
Jesus Christ.
My,
my buddy Andy stumped,
heals the world record for the longest
in one of those flying body suits.
The longest distance.
What are you traveling?
Thirty miles or something?
Fucking nuts.
What did he jump off of?
It jumps off everything.
Planes,
whatever.
He'll jump off a rocket if you let him.
He's crazy.
He's a navy seal.
He's out of his fucking mind.
Out of his mind.
The squirrel suits look funny.
Shit.
The.
Oh yeah,
I would never do it,
but that looks fun as hell.
They get real close to the ground and
then they hit the ground occasionally
and then.
Well,
he's humble.
Real sports.
He's like his fucking toes.
Oh,
that's right.
Clip something with his toes.
Just came back to Frank Gallo.
Brad Gum was like a guy.
Yeah.
Has a bit of a death wish.
And the other report is like,
yeah,
he does.
He does.
He was just laying on the ground like
moaning in this agony.
The worst agony I've ever heard that was
that,
don't please don't.
I'm not gonna tell you what it is
because it ain't gonna play like haunted
me,
but I get this guy on one of these
youtube videos,
the guy who was climbing up the tree to
chop it down or something and he just
fell and he went straight down and
shattered both of his legs and dude,
don't pull that up.
These,
I've never walked.
I've always look away the sound.
He was just in the woods because he had
filmed himself doing.
He was just the,
what'd you say?
Like fucking over and over again.
Just like his soul.
I mean like if you get,
if he had a fucking loaded nine
millimeter within reach,
he would have blew his brains out.
Like that was the level of pain.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That happens.
A lot of guys,
when they,
uh,
make tree stands,
they setup tree stands and some guys are
tough guys.
They don't want to wear a harness.
Like they have these harnesses that most
people where they strap around your
waist,
they strap around your legs and then it
hooks to the tree so you can't fall off
the tree,
but there's a lot of guys that want to
be tough guys,
so they climb up these tree stands and
they don't have a harness on and they
fall off the tree stand and you know
you're falling 30 feet,
whatever it is,
and you're just.
You just fucked up.
Then you got to cry out of the woods or
not,
or someone finds you days later and you
started death.
Is anybody fallen out of the tree stand
and then getting eaten by what they were
just kind of.
I'm sure.
I'm sure that's happened for bears
because people go bear hunting and they
did.
They'd go bear hunting and tree stands a
guarantee.
If someone's been eating that way,
hundred percent,
100,000
percent,
no,
no chance.
That hasn't.
To have enough confidence in my ability
to secure a tree stand correctly past a
certain height and knowing that a bear
was going to become a tooth.
That's just to those two factors of,
of falling that length and then also,
yeah,
it may be right in front of a bear.
What's more fucked up is how fast the
bear can get up.
A tree bears.
I've seen that one.
They run up a fucking tree,
like they're running on the ground.
It's insane.
The only up to a certain size.
That's what's,
what's weird.
Like when they get to be like 400 pounds
plus they really can't make it up trees
anymore.
They're too heavy.
They're nails can't support their
bodyweight on Tuesdays are for
grizzlies.
They've begun to wade into the water to
get this salmon.
Oh,
want to do it?
It's really more and more black bears
then grizzlies or run up trees.
But they,
uh,
they run up those fucking trees.
They just brought it up and the up like,
you can't.
Yeah.
There's a youtube video of a guy like,
he's,
he's like,
one of those stands in the fucking
thing,
looks up and just runs up the tree next
to him and now it's above him.
Yeah,
in seconds.
In seconds.
That's like when you get in fighting in
a football stadium,
you want to be in the row behind the
guy,
so you're punching down.
Oh for sure.
Bear went from being on the field too,
like two rows behind this guy and the
guy sitting there with his fucking.
I don't know what he had.
Bow and Arrow or something.
Yeah.
It's bone now.
The bear doesn't know what a bow and
Arrow is.
You can kind of just slowly turned and
looked at him,
shoot him right in the nose.
Can you?
Uh,
you might be able to,
but it's not going to kill them
instantly.
The problem with that is they're going
to get a hold of you,
like have a bear was right there in
front of you and you shot it with a bow
and arrow.
There's two things that can happen.
One,
it could run away or to.
It can attack you.
And if it decides to attack you by the
time it expires,
it's going to take like 30 seconds for
it to die.
And by the time it expires it's kind of
fucking mall.
You.
Yeah know.
But Leonardo,
he got attacked for like a minute and a
half.
Do it if you seen hidden figures.
I found out that Leonardo story was
supposedly based on a true story.
We had Steve Rinella in here was a
historian on the ancient wild west Shit
and he told me it was all bullshit and
he's like,
first of all,
the guy did get mauled by a bear.
Yes.
But he got away and he crawled back to
camp and that's it.
Like he didn't have a son.
His son never got killed.
Like there was no sudden like they made
all that shit up.
Yeah.
Nobody fell off the cliff.
But if,
if you actually made movies,
how shit really happens.
It would be.
It'd be like you'd have to watch that
guy in the fucking restaurant with you
not looking at people.
That's how they would be.
That's why people go to movies because
you gotta have like a.
well my mom,
my wife was watching that women's march
after awhile he couldn't watch it
anymore because it wasn't going
anywhere.
It was 100,000
people standing outside of grain with
each other.
They will all in the same page.
They would.
There was nothing like it didn't go
anywhere.
No arrests all over the country.
Millions of people marched.
No arrests.
That's pretty amazing.
That's because they're women.
You can't hit them.
That's what it was.
If those were guys,
eventually the cops would be sick of
them and then they'd send a plain
clothes guy to go down and light a car
on fire.
Well,
cops were there taking pictures with
them.
Cops were wearing those pussy hats.
It was cops.
There's photos of cops with a pink hats
with the with ears,
like kitty cat hats.
No casinos,
no.
He did amazing.
Like one comment the guy makes on a bus
with billy Bush with grabbing them by
the pussy and that literally spawns
a march.
I'll tell you what's even more amazing
is that those hats are all going to be
thrown out and end up at the bottom of
the ocean in a fucking octopus is going
to suffocate at.
Wonderful.
Look at these cops with the pussy.
Hats off stupid.
Those are our protectors.
They're serving and protecting right
there with pussy.
Hats on.
I,
I'm anti ribbon bands,
all of that,
all of that shit.
I just fucking like,
can't you just say what the agenda is?
Do we all have to dress in the same
fucking silly hat like this as a.
If Ya'll at mit.
People love that though.
I know that loves the 20 comedians.
No,
you,
I'm with you.
I don't like it either.
I think it's a,
it's group.
Think.
How dare those people do what they like
to do.
Joe,
Donald think they liked to do it.
They just like to just get together.
It's just a big just refusal of
admitting that this guy won some crazy
popularity contests that we put on every
couple of years.
They should just get together with each
other and they should create shit that
makes money.
That's what they should do.
Make money,
make money,
and then they have to come to you.
It's like podcasts,
right?
No one gave a fuck what we would do and
then all of a sudden we started making
money.
They'll say,
hey,
you want to read for Legal Zoom?
That's how you do it.
Well,
they can definitely generate some money
that way.
Right.
I mean,
it's a lot of fucking people marching.
You think about there was 970,000
people.
It's a Whitney.
Cummings told me in La alone,
they thought 80,000
people were coming.
It was almost a million.
It was a million.
Where were they?
Downtown?
Oh,
thank God.
Because it was a swarm of humanity.
Oh,
that's great.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
go downtown.
Thank God they didn't come to my fucking
neighborhood.
What was the last time we saw a protest
against the president like that though?
Especially a new president.
It's never.
It's a new time.
Like with the Internet now they can.
They can organize these things quickly
and get together.
Yeah.
I mean I don't.
I don't know what to belief.
Like that whole picture of of trump's
inauguration versus Obama's
inauguration.
They put the photos side by side and I'm
just supposed to automatically without
any checks and balances,
be like,
okay,
that's what those photos are of.
I'm supposed to believe that Bill
Clinton was checking out donald trump's
wife without seeing what he's looking
at,
and then hillary vaguely looking back in
his direction vaguely,
and people are here through his soul.
How could you tell she was turned
around?
Oh,
we'll show you because we've watched it
a thousand times,
but he's looking at.
He says it.
He says,
well,
he says it.
He literally says it.
He moves his mouth.
He goes,
Ivanka,
once he had,
come on,
we want to watch it together.
Watch this.
Look,
look,
go,
fullscreen.
Jamey.
Watch Ivanka.
Go back,
go back.
Come back.
He says it.
Replace it a couple times here,
right here.
Watch this.
Look at her.
Looking at him.
She ain't vaguely looking back.
She's peering through his soul as he
stares at her and look at that shit.
Gonna.
Look,
look,
he is or she turns away.
Immediately watch it.
He's looking at
you don't know what's going on.
He's looking right at Ivanka.
He says it.
Go back to it.
Go back to go back to the beginning,
the very beginning,
the very beginning.
You're sending them.
Know Jamie,
you missed it.
Go all the way to the very beginning,
the very beginning of the video.
Now we already missed it.
You missed it because he says it.
Beginning Scott.
This.
Okay.
Okay,
here we go.
Ivanka said,
I see the car.
Oh,
I see it.
I don't see it here,
mom.
Well,
what's let's.
Let's make up something for the Air
Force Guy.
Let's see what to see.
What the fuck he's doing.
Ivanka and the sunglasses right there.
Jerking off.
That's why it's head isn't moving
slowly.
Masturbating on your.
You denying that.
Look,
she's given him.
Look at that fucking looks.
She's getting them.
She's stare and look at the Shah when he
shoots over at her and she takes a big
deep breath.
Just him look at it and he stared her
down and she looked at what's right.
He's the fucking man of the
relationship.
Watch.
You can watch it again.
Come on,
come on.
And she,
she has her mouth open and she turns
away like,
oh Jesus.
Hi everyone.
I'm Ivanka trump steaks.
I tracy,
Lord sister in the eighties.
He's got good looking kids.
He does.
Amazing.
She's good looking too.
She's amazing.
Good for him,
good for him,
and if Bill Clinton wants to vaguely
look in the direction of a beautiful
woman off camera that none of us want to
know when you want to convict him on
what he might've said.
Ivy,
he might've been like fucking like
lightheaded.
I think he was.
I think it was growing like inside
with his mouth shut.
You could not convict anybody who's
convicted in a court of law.
You are legal or illegal.
You are judging podcast humanity.
I am judging them.
You just send them to the chair.
But the podcast court is a lot like
civil court.
You know,
criminal,
criminal court,
you need a lot more evidence.
That's why I got off in criminal court.
I never understood that.
He gets off when you need more evidence,
less evidence.
He has to give away all his shit.
I'm not saying that.
That doesn't make any sense.
No,
it doesn't.
It doesn't.
Why do you need more evidence that he
did it or he didn't?
You shouldn't be like acquitted.
You didn't do it.
Oh,
now you got to give me your,
your trophies in your house.
Yeah.
What is that?
And you fucking tie tacks.
How the fuck does that work?
How can they have a civil court where
you have less evidence and that's where
all your money goes.
Like your freedom is worth more.
It works out because um,
or sort of worked out.
I think he moved to Florida to get
around it.
I don't know what the fuck happened but
like,
because I think he did it,
but what am I basing that on?
You know,
Shit.
I mean he's in jail for a very innocuous
crime trying to get his own shit back
with a guy in the room that had a gun.
The guy didn't even brandished the gun.
He tried to get his shit back.
He is stolen.
Memorable thing on that.
And,
and they,
they made,
they fucked up by a,
they made some threat that then it made
it kidnapping.
And they did,
they did all these little fucking things
and he killed,
you know,
he killed two white people.
So that's the big.
The white court's got him years later.
That's the big one.
That's really what mean it's complete
bullshit because the reality is if he
didn't kill those fucking two people at
least where people didn't think that he
killed those fucking two people.
If he did that,
I mean they,
they,
he was Oj they and he was still on
fucking nfl today or whatever.
Like he probably would have been in and
out and that would have been it.
He might not even done any time.
They might've like sided with him
because these people were stealing his
stuff.
He would have agreed to do was couple of
signings at fucking Caesar's sides of
football helmets and it would have been
over seas.
It would have been over.
There.
Would have been.
It would have gone to the Venetian where
they have a boat rides and.
Oh yeah.
Oh Jay.
That's a weird one though.
Everybody's asking about anything.
He's just taking pictures and doing boat
rides.
No signing folks know.
Signing.
Still take pictures though.
Can't use your camera.
It'll be up online.
Caesar's dot com.
Yeah.
That'll be it.
Don't touch them.
Just stand next to him.
That's a weird case,
right,
because that's a case where we know that
that's not why he's in jail,
but we're all happy.
Um,
well,
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't know how I feel about all that
fucking shit.
I mean,
I think he got,
did it.
He did it.
He did.
He wrote a book about it.
Remember that if I did it,
I want to tell you or something.
I think it was called the.
If I did it was that this is how I would
do it now.
Yeah.
Whatever happened to that book.
That book never got published,
right?
Like no publisher wanted to.
They originally had a publishing deal,
but then is
difference about all.
This is why I.
That rubs me the wrong way that he's in
jail is because all those fucking white
dudes that did all that shit like blown
up churches with black people in it.
Like back in the sixties,
they would literally be sitting there
laughing during the trial and they would
get totally acquitted and then black
people weren't allowed to come along and
take that fucking four wheelers in their
hillbillies.
Shit.
This stills afterwards in like a civil
court,
they just completely got away with.
That's why it,
it still seems kind of fucked up.
It's for sale,
but they changed the uh,
the uh,
judge awarded the golden family,
the rights to the book.
So they get the publishing.
Oh,
so you can buy it.
Yeah.
So it says it's by Fred and Kim Goldman,
but oh my God,
they didn't write it all and what they
did.
Oh,
they took away if.
No,
they,
they put the.
If,
uh,
I forget how I did it because I just saw
a thing on the F is written in red
letters inside the eye.
Oh Wow.
There it is.
That right there.
That's crazy.
And it's written blood red.
Wow.
Well,
what,
what cases are you talking about?
A guy's blowing up.
I mean,
obviously there were some horrendous
civil rights violations that took place
in the sixties and the fifties as well.
And well,
you know,
all from slavery on from the 18,
60 [inaudible] just saying,
yeah.
And then the table gets turned and this
guy does it,
but he has the money to get off.
But then he still pays for it in a way,
so that's why it just,
it doesn't,
it still doesn't seem,
you know,
it's good because,
he killed two people,
so he's,
he's not out there,
but it's,
it's,
I don't know,
different crime though.
I mean what he did was a crime of
passion against an ex wife who happen to
be with some other guy.
Those other crimes are in a lot of ways
more heinous because they're completely
race related.
If you go back to some of the lynchings
and some of those horrific guys,
you know,
they got.
They fucking took pictures.
Yeah.
You ever see those photos are the
scariest photos.
Scalia's vote.
Yeah.
Kids smiling and they have evil and they
have like evil and like the kids have
like,
I remember,
uh,
Patrice would show me those photos and
would point it.
The kid's going,
look at that girl bill.
She's like,
probably 48 right now.
Where the fuck is she?
What does she do for a living?
And I was just like,
wow.
It's true.
They're out there.
Yup.
Yeah.
Well,
when you think about how many people
have actually gotten arrested for murder
versus how many murders get just never
solved is,
and it's a crazy number when everybody
looks at those fucking TV shows about
cops and most crimes get solved.
But the reality of murders,
I think it's like something like 70
percent go on,
solved something really nutty like that.
Yeah.
I talked to a cop about that one time
and I won't say it over the year.
It's fucking brutal.
We won't say it over the air because
it's that bad.
Well,
I just don't want to fucking murder.
Yeah.
Give people the green light.
Oh yeah.
Because we tried to come up with the
perfect murder,
right?
Me and this other guy to Rosa on this
podcast.
And then we had this cop listened to
listen to our,
uh,
our plants.
Mine was the funniest guys go.
All right.
So me and a buddy and he goes,
it's over.
He goes,
you already cut what you involve.
Somebody else.
It goes,
somebody's going to get scared and
they're gonna.
They're gonna.
Cut a deal.
He goes,
it was fucking hilarious,
dude.
I got like literally and I had worked
this whole thing out in New Jersey.
We're trying to top each other to see
which one was better and I got like,
it's like when you watch American Ninja
Warrior and the person stumbles on those
first thing and it goes right into the
water.
That's what happened.
So he told us basically how to get out.
I guess,
you know,
the audio does exist.
So he basically said if you have no
priors and nobody fucking knows,
you know,
you've never done anything and if you,
if you were to do it,
somebody just completely not even
connected to.
Yeah.
That's a buddy of mine has said the same
thing.
Nobody saw it.
Like there's nothing like there's no
way.
There's no.
Because there's no rational connection
to it.
There's no trail to follow.
Have you heard of this stuff that
they're,
they're developing that's essentially
micro cameras with gps units that are
the size smaller than a grain of rice,
like literally like sand.
And the idea is that eventually they're
going to spread this shit everywhere and
there will be cameras that record
everything everywhere you go.
And it's just a matter of time,
like now there's more cameras now today
than they've ever been before.
Right.
Phones and surveillance cameras and
security cameras.
That one right now,
right there.
There's more cameras now than ever been
before.
But it's nothing compared to what they
have potentially lined up for the future
that they're going to have like grains
of sand cameras everywhere.
You just vacuum your house to scoop them
up.
I'm talking about out there in the
street.
They don't give a shit and it's fucking
show me jerking off.
You don't to.
Can I at least have that target?
Will there ever be a time where there's
no privacy?
That's the question.
Will there be a time with the zero
privacy?
Well,
it doesn't exist.
This is the thing.
The reason why they're going to get away
with it is because people have such
fucking voyeurs.
Like the more private it is,
the less I want to see it because I
always think like,
I wouldn't want someone to do that to
me.
Right.
So anytime there's like a,
Oh God,
I can't even think of an example.
But there's just,
there's just been some micro celebrity
photos that got leaked where they got
into their icloud.
They like naked photos of.
I never look at those fucking things.
It really.
If somebody,
you know,
intercepts,
like a cell phone call,
I don't listen to those things.
I just,
I just think,
uh,
your moral.
If it feels gross.
Yeah.
Good.
Well,
good for you.
You're moral,
you're more a person.
That's good.
Yeah.
And it may not.
I don't know.
I,
I'm,
I wouldn't say I'm a moral person,
but had just in that,
in that instant,
maybe I am.
You're definitely moral moral.
Don't put me on that pedestal.
You are.
I mean,
you're not,
you're not ridiculous.
I mean you're just a guy,
but do you have morals?
You gotta get slightly annoyed and a gas
station and for the rest of the day you
have a lot of work.
I've got a lot of work,
lot of work ahead of me.
You should get a punching bag.
I have a speed bag.
That's not good enough.
I guess it is now because speed bags
just,
it's not rich is no real system exists.
And I hit it and I enjoy it.
I blew a bet you do.
And it's good.
I do enjoy it.
And then I go and I play some drums and
I enjoy that.
I'm,
I'm not degrading it,
but I'm saying it's not good enough.
I thought you were very judgmental.
I am.
I told you certain things.
I jumped in that I can hold in these
beautiful hands of mine told me it
wasn't real because people are fucking
weird.
It's a weird position to hold your hand.
Seen hidden figures.
The habit I heard.
It's good.
The women got us on the real break.
Speed bags versus heavy bags down in a
way that you've never.
You've never heard.
Oh beautiful.
That's beautiful.
No heavy bag.
Won't even sit there and fuck up my
hands and fuck up your hands for this
because my technique will be fucked up
because I don't have the time Joe,
to go to the Dojo like you have for 30
fucking years and get it down and I'm
going to go in there and I'm going to
fuck up my wrist and I'll hit it with
the wrong.
Well,
yeah,
once you get a water bottle,
your hands get a water bag.
Water bags are like literally like
you're punching into water.
It's heavy.
We live in a desert,
but it just goes,
gosh,
same water will be there forever.
It's raining now.
Kept plenty,
right?
They said the drought is over.
Like it's like,
no,
we have enough water right now.
This now has to last us.
Who?
Who the knows when it's going
to rain again,
somebody like the mayor is some shit.
Said that out here,
but drive is now officially over now.
Reduce bag out.
There's taken an extra long shower,
will listen to ears.
Never stopped modern.
Those fucking golf courses.
The golf course.
This is a huge problem,
but they they.
You know what?
They stay.
Stop watering the median strip on sunset
and beverly hills.
That was unsettling.
I was like,
wow.
They let enrich people's grass.
Go fucking Brown.
This is scary.
This is getting real.
Well,
they had rules,
right?
Like you were only supposed to water
your thing at night and you can only
water at a certain amount of times a
day.
Like when it comes to your lawn,
but they didn't have those rules with
golf courses.
Do they golf courses?
Like especially private ones,
they spend millions and millions of
gallons of water every year just in La.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Do you golf?
No.
Good for you.
I don't.
It's so fucking mind.
Numbingly boring.
I can't get into a sport where there's
nobody trying to stop me.
If you need to get yourself,
I'm going to forgive myself.
You'll get them the next toll.
Like I don't give a shit.
It's so fucking um,
I respect it.
It's,
it's.
I don't,
I don't think it's a sport,
but I think the,
the people that are the best at it are
athletic,
but I have seen it.
The people that I've seen do that,
I'm telling you if you throw a ball at
them,
they would tense up.
They just don't have any athletic
ability.
They will get on a golf course and they
can keep it on the course and they can
shoot,
you know,
they can break 100.
You know,
I,
I just,
uh,
oh.
In the,
in the fucking pageantry of it,
all,
the fucking clothes and the bags that
either is that don't think there's ever
been a fucking sport because there's so
many fat fuck non non athletic people
playing it.
There has never been a sport that is
adjusted.
The equipment,
the ball,
the fucking,
the clubs that you use to give you more
distance to help you hit it straighter.
It's like literally the only thing
missing on a fucking driver now is
training wheels.
It's fucking Bro.
They should just have it,
guide you back and then come,
come right through us.
Truly baseball never went to aluminum
bats.
If they did it,
they looked at the college level.
But at the pro level they just like,
no man,
you can't,
you can't do this.
Um,
they but they.
But baseball when they,
when they were going through,
you know,
no one was watching it and it wasn't
exciting,
you know,
they,
they made the stadium smaller that
juiced up the ball.
People on Roids,
they look the other way like,
well Huh,
I didn't know that.
And they just had these King Kong guys
going up there and just smashing them
over the fence and I'm.
But I'm just saying like,
like I dunno,
I like when guys got busted for Cork in
the bat.
I thought that was the most ridiculous
thing to get in trouble for.
Put a cork inside the bat.
Bats would break what's in Japan.
But that was always.
That was.
Oh,
that's another one too.
I couldn't watch.
That's just so embarrassing to try to
pick it up and just cover up the cork.
Well this is what you should do.
Like if you're going to do that like the
entire time you're a pro,
you should.
The bad boys should never have to deal
with your shit.
You always get.
It's okay.
Sunny.
I got into like,
look at me.
So down to earth.
So then when you finally get bust with
you,
corked bat,
when you go to pick it up,
no one's going to look at you weird.
But the thing is these,
you know,
these,
these majorly baseball guys,
they just fucking dropped the bat and
some little eight year old scurries out
and picks it up.
So the second that you give a fuck about
that little eight year old,
like,
I think you've run enough there,
sonny boy,
like I think they realized that,
uh,
that's on the outcomes over.
You could see the cork,
right when it snaps out.
I mean the,
the,
the average sports fan,
we be to lie.
No,
I said that a month ago.
I can't think of the fucking bat breaks.
I have no idea.
It's not until they pick it up and they
start looking at it.
And then the announcer literally tells
me,
Oh,
they're inspecting his bad.
This could possibly be a court situation
then.
Then I know.
How much of a difference does it make to
have cork in the bat?
It's just,
it's just a competitive edge.
I mean,
you still have to have the barrel of the
bat meet the ball,
which is so fucking hard.
You still have to do that.
But it could be the difference between
going and getting to the warning track
and going over and just hitting the wall
and getting into a double or something.
That's the only.
That's it.
Just that little amount.
It's just gives it just a little little
little push.
No Shit.
Sammy socials.
Downfall began 13 years ago.
Today.
That's Sammy Sosa got busted with Cork.
So what do they do?
They drill a hole in the bat and then
just hollow it out somehow or another.
What the fuck's going on in that one?
That picture you just showed.
What's that?
That might've been the one.
They picked it up off the ground.
They're cutting grass or some show.
So I didn't know.
I thought there was like a,
they,
they drilled a hole.
I was trying to follow this down.
It says,
uh,
if a court has been courted transfers
less energy to the ball,
which makes sense to me.
But transfer is less energy to the ball.
Huh?
I don't know.
Well that doesn't make any sense.
Yeah,
that doesn't make sense to me.
Although I have no physics.
Well why don't you?
Uh,
well it seems to me that it makes more
sense that if a bat was solid,
that does make sense.
You give them that with solid,
more massive a transformer,
but if you would be able to swing it
faster if it was lighter.
So you thought it was because it was
more of a spongy thing.
Yeah,
that's what I thought too.
You know what?
And that's right because I think they
drove from the top.
Thank God you said that because it was
probably a bunch of people screaming
right now.
Fucking you fucking moron.
It's lighter.
You Cut.
Oh,
that's what it is.
We start like they had it like up
against the,
uh,
like flush with it.
Dude,
that doesn't make any sense.
That doesn't not like,
think about that.
That's like having a nerf bad up there.
The fucking bat would break.
I thought it was,
which I guess it does bounce more boring
for your listeners.
For the record I said I had no physics
background,
so definitely don't know.
I don't.
Yeah,
I would think that it would,
it would hit harder.
Right.
It's just so it's just a matter of it
being faster,
speed coming through.
Interesting.
Which is why they switched it.
When they're warming up,
they swing all those other bats.
They swing two right
now.
One would they put a weight on the bat
and I swing that.
Yep.
Yeah.
Which actually helps.
Some people say it helps.
Some people say it doesn't help.
Why don't you guys do that and yet you
guys like run with like weighted vests
on through the mountains.
Yeah,
it's bad for your joints,
but some guys do it the best way to do
it as hiking,
hiking with weighted vest is okay,
but running really not such a good idea.
Especially.
There's a lot of guys that do it though.
They'll put a weighted vest on.
They run on concrete hard assets and
that Tito Ortiz fight.
I saw Tito won.
He Won.
He choked him out.
It was quick fight.
He got caught in a good team early in
the fight,
but child lost the guillotine and Tito
gun on top.
Tito took us back and he got like.
It was like sort of a rear naked choke,
but more of like a face crush.
He just Tito's,
just a gorilla.
Just kinda get.
A lot of people thought it was a work.
They thought it was fake,
that it was a fake fight because he did
it so easily.
Well,
it looked fake because the choke wasn't
in right,
but it wasn't fake.
He just kinda he.
He did what we call Gundam.
You goons,
somebody like there's some times like
you could just get someone's head and
just crush it and you're goon them.
Whereas the right technique to do that,
to make the right technique is you go
under the chin,
you wrap your head around the back of
the neck and that way that he can just
get maximum leverage and it's perfect
technique,
but he just seemed lower jaw to the back
of his head.
If someone's eye socket.
So like right there and I get their head
and I'm fresh early in the fight because
you're not even tired and you get
fucking crush their head.
You can goon somebody.
There's a lot of guys have been gooned
you know that word dude?
Yeah.
Gooning Jujitsu word like this.
There are certain techniques you do
like,
you know,
it's funny is it just totally defines
what the second one says.
I know what that is.
He just had no respect for my style
walkthrough.
All my pussy kicks and hits and just
fucking,
you know,
grabbed my nostril right.
It right it.
Right.
You know,
what do you watch?
Game of thrones?
Um,
I stopped.
My wife would just would refuse to get
into it.
So,
uh,
you know,
do you remember the mountain?
I just,
I didn't want them out and grab that
guy's head and he crushed it.
He gunned him,
grabbed his head and he just smashed his
head with his hands.
The only one I saw was when that little
shit king,
you know,
didn't like the song this guy saying and
he fucking goes,
all right,
rip his tongue out.
Yeah.
And I was just like,
what?
Like,
who the fuck would listen to this little
shit to this guy?
So he slips,
the guy,
gets on top of him,
grabs him,
and he just fucking goons him.
He grabs his head and he fucking goons
them.
Boom man,
what the fuck?
That guy is fucking gigantic too.
Like she's upset.
Meanwhile the other guy was killed on
it.
I love is watching a fight to the death,
but they've never seen it done like
that.
So there's always that level of gross
out.
It's like working your way through porn.
Yeah.
Will you just start off with the basic
sit and all of a sudden you just go into
darker and darker rooms?
That's the same thing when it watch
watching people's fucking get hurt.
Yeah.
Right.
Like torture.
And some of the death is more terrifying
to people than just shooting them from a
distance as a sniper.
Yeah.
You could watch the.
Yeah,
fucking like the fact that human beings
understand pain and then they inflict it
like slowly and other people is,
is the most fucking like animalistic.
Like every time I hear that shit that
people get that little literally torture
another human being like how you go home
at the end of the day
they think and you did something good is
just fucking out.
I just got to get information out of
people,
Bill Burr,
the.
Some people out there that know things.
You've got to find out what they know
in.
The best way to do it is to cut their
fingers off.
Well,
haven't they proved that when you start
to cut,
just to tell someone to cut your finger
off,
they will tell you whatever the fuck you
want.
I would,
yeah,
but sometimes sometimes they won't.
Sometimes they'll tell you some fake
shit and like how many do you think
you're getting the real stuff?
Probably nine.
And they think about that last thing
that they need to open up their iphone.
Like alright,
we're just open to the refrigerator
drawer finger.
I want to still be able to finger
somebody.
What can you do?
Yeah,
I,
I just,
I don't know.
I mean it's a look.
W W,
w what are war crimes?
How about that?
How about,
you know,
you're not allowed to do certain things,
not a lot of gas people,
but you're allowed to drop a nuclear
bomb on them.
You're allowed to do that.
It's,
it shouldn't be an issue like war at
this point.
It shouldn't be legal.
War should be illegal.
So what do you do when someone attacks?
Just take them?
They've shown.
No,
no,
I'm just saying that we should be
progressed in that we should be.
Yeah,
I'm surprised as the rest of the world.
I'm in people,
common people,
right?
I'll do it.
We're not exactly civilized.
Um,
I don't think anybody's going to war.
It's not a civil fucking thought.
It would be great if everybody,
because you need regular people to do
it.
So if everybody was just like,
yeah,
we're not doing it.
Yeah,
if you guys want to go to war,
you guys go fight each other to death,
but we'll fucking watch it on page.
That would be the ultimate but note.
But there's a complete lack of trust
with,
you know,
different countries,
different cultures,
different races and all that.
But if you could somehow get everybody
on the same page to be just like,
yeah,
you know,
we're,
we're not doing that anymore.
So you guys find out a different way to
fucking take over the world is something
that,
you know,
but you know,
that,
that could never happen.
You get ketamine,
Jesus,
he couldn't,
couldn't have watched the apprentice and
you watched him to try to get a,
you know,
uh,
Vince Neil and uh,
the culture club guy,
they can't even get on the same
celebrity apprentice and they want you
to think they can't get on the same
fucking page to write a song.
So there's no way you're ever going to
end war right there.
They asked me to do that show celebrity
apprentice back when fear factor came
back years ago and I was thinking about
doing it.
And I'm so glad I didn't do it now
because would have like me and trump
didn't get along.
What have you thought it was a cunt.
And now I became president.
I was like,
fucking enemies with the president.
Imagine that.
Like Rosie O'donnell right now,
she probably barely
leaves her house.
She's probably just sitting at home
going,
Oh fuck,
fuck,
you get audited or something.
She used to shit on them constantly and
then he started shitting on her.
They would go to war with each other.
She was on the view and she would shit
on him and make fun of his hair and make
fun of him and make fun of his life and
his family and right.
And then he became fucking president and
then in the debates he was mocking her
and the debates like she was,
because Clinton said something about the
things that he says about women,
which I always have a real fucking
problem with,
you know,
because she was like,
you've called women this and you've
called women that like,
okay,
he's called people that and some of
those people happen to be women.
He's also called men that and they know
that's one.
One of the things that he said when he
said she's a nasty woman,
why?
They latched on,
like he was attacking him.
She is a woman and he's saying that
she's nasty.
He's a nasty man or he's not a good man
or whatever.
Exactly,
exactly.
It's.
We became this thing where women like,
you're not supposed to have mock women
make fun of women.
Like are we equal or are we not?
Because if we're equal,
I should be able to shit on you the way
I should on everybody.
If I don't like
your character,
you know,
it was a bad move.
Was that that t shirt that was the
future is feminine.
What's that?
It was just this thing that these women
were wearing it.
When I went down to go vote and it's
just like you are so fucking you making
people not want to vote for Clinton
because it should be.
The future is like some sort of unity
and what you're doing is like,
oh,
the future is we're going to fucking now
do to you what we've been complaining
about work it's going to be so then
right.
Then you lose any sort of feeling of
like,
oh,
this person's a victim or like,
this person's a good person.
I said,
oh,
what you are is a complete fucking
psycho.
Who just hasn't got to sit at the
controls yet?
Now you want to be that and then you're
gonna.
Now you're gonna Ram it down everybody's
throat and it's just like,
there needs to be a.
it's why I can't watch CNN or Fox
because this,
I can't just sit there and listen.
I mean,
as much as I rant and rave,
which is fucking pretty ironic.
I can't sit there and listen to people
screaming and yelling at each other
because they don't want to.
They don't want to come together.
They don't want to find what's right.
They just want to.
When they have a side.
Yeah.
And it just have a side and then don't
look at the other side.
Yeah.
I wear a red tie.
So I argue the red tie.
Shit,
you got a blue ties.
He argued that it's fucking childish.
Hashtag [inaudible]
with her,
you know,
the um,
with her thing was driving me fucking
crazy to like,
are you.
What do you mean you're with her?
Like is just her.
Is it about a woman or is it about who's
the right person to run the fucking
country?
It's because it's not her
that see you voted democratic.
I thought those fucking,
you know,
CNN,
you see that they,
you know,
they kind of fucking boxed out Bernie
Sanders and they might have.
It was almost like a fight and he
might've been a better match up.
Who knows?
He was away way better
match up.
He was,
he wasn't compromised.
Like if you want to talk about someone
who's financially compromised,
he wasn't compromised.
He was like maybe the only guy ever
running for president that wasn't
completely tied the financial system.
They can always find shit on you be
like,
well,
you know,
he was absent this.
He didn't vote for that love.
And they try to get them on.
They didn't vote for this and they
didn't vote for that.
And it's just like,
well,
what was fucking attached to it?
And I don't get why that's legal where
it's like,
Hey,
you want clean drinking water for
children?
And it's like he voted no against that.
And then you see like what is,
what is attached to it is like,
oh yeah,
they're going to start fracking next to
a fucking,
you know exactly hospital or whatever
that I don't know.
The CNN Fox divide the left and the
right device never been greater in this
country than right now there is no one
objective.
News source does not one source.
It just tells you what's going on and
doesn't do it.
Biased perspective.
But I like to write.
But I think that divide only exists
between the people that watched that
shit.
It's Kinda like people like do you watch
the UFC?
Do you not watch UFC?
If you watch UFC you're fucking into the
shit.
And I think there's just news junkies
out there that just mainline that shit
and they're the ones that where that
divide is like that.
But someone like myself,
like I,
I can,
I can listen to somebody.
I try to anyways,
like whatever your point of view is,
I try to listen to it because I try to
keep that shit out of my head because a,
it gives me anxiety.
I can't fucking watch it.
I can't watch it.
My mother was,
uh,
was watching last time I went home,
my mother was watching this.
This kid's thinks we get like little
nephews and nieces and I literally
couldn't even get through the fucking
kids movie because towards the end they
just kept putting these obstacles in the
fucking anxiety.
It just built on me.
I'm not built like that.
I can't handle it.
Just literally watching a kids movie
watching this thing going like,
can you just get them to the end where
he gets the fucking thing and you roll
the credits and it's fine.
It is having like,
you know,
and then the little robot almost falls
into the trash bin.
I know he's not going to,
but I just,
I can't even handle that.
Xcel is no fucking way.
I'm going to sit there and watch a news.
I hope
that people like you are the future.
I hope that this.
We realized that this fucking left
versus right things stupid.
But people love to be on a team.
They love it.
They love to be on our side is winning
and your site can go fuck themselves.
And they love to win.
We won.
How many people you just see on twitter
that was like,
we won.
Get over it.
We want.
I saw a lot of that.
A lot of we won and can handle it.
We won
Magda.
What is magazine?
Make America great again.
Oh,
Hashtag Mag A.
Hey.
You know people have a right to tweet.
What are you going to go?
Oh yeah,
they definitely do.
It's interesting.
We're working it out.
I think we're working it out as a
civilization.
That's what I like.
Had a little bit of faith.
You came in with the cameras and the
grains of sand.
That's the future.
It's gonna.
Take some time.
That's gonna.
Take about 50 years.
I'm going to buy a fucking leaf blower.
Just walking around.
Just fucking walking down the street
blowing.
But meanwhile they'll have video footage
of you because you won't be able to get
all the grains.
That'd be everywhere.
The literally be covering the surface of
this,
of this planet,
like dirt.
Little,
little tiny cameras.
Got To be a thing that
I always thought like,
I don't know if I.
I read about this because I'm always
late night,
I fucking go on the Internet and as I
fall asleep so I can't remember if this
is my idea.
Somebody came up with it would be really
cool for like say if you're like at some
level of celebrity where everybody's
always taken a picture of you.
If you could wear his suit that
anticipated the camera flash and as
their cameras flashed you would flash
back at them and then they couldn't get
anything and then he could just sit
there eating your soup is everybody's
taken pictures of you and they would all
go back to the developing Rome or
whatever the fuck they do.
Look into their cameras and not
understand what was going on.
Would just be like a Ufo landed in front
of them.
Yeah.
There has to be a way like I like.
I feel like future money is encountering
all that.
There it is antipop Razzi close.
It's a blazer and I knew that I was too
stupid to come up with that.
How does he not captured?
How does three m reflection stuff that's
on like a lot of shoes and some other
claw.
They never turn the flash off though.
Then it's dark and you can't see the
people,
which is the opposite reason I've taken
the fuck.
Does it work?
Yeah,
I'll show.
I'll get a better photo.
This was just an article.
Here's some of the folks I knew.
I was too dumb to come up with that,
so they're wearing hoods that stopped
like oh,
see their face or anything and just see
the clothes,
which is not really what the reason they
want to take your photo that I mean it
properly.
You can see what guy is.
There might be a reason way to get
around,
but for now that's new.
Those new cameras that they have now are
so good on camera.
Phones are so good in low light that you
don't even need that anymore.
You just take a photo of it.
I mean they can capture incredible
images and pretty low light with his
iphone seven like tmz.
You guys aren't using iphone of course
for a reason.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
A strange times comes to privacy.
Slowly but surely it's all going away.
We're taking collars.
What are you going to move?
Bill the mountains.
I've,
I'm not fighting any of this shit.
I'm just going to hang out.
Just look at it.
Disappointed.
Why?
Why do we have to do this?
Come on guys.
Let's just go back to playing checkers.
Woodland would.
It's not going to happen.
We're going to keep going forward.
I'm a little nervous about it.
Let's get out.
Let's come on.
I got the rest of the day ahead of me,
man.
I can't go down this rabbit hole.
It's all good.
You're going to be fine.
Especially now.
You have a little tiny baby that just
happened.
I tell jokes with them.
She's the best.
So,
um,
what's her future going to be like when
it comes to this shit?
That's what's bizarre.
Like what are our kids going to have to
deal with 50 years from now?
Like what kind of bizarre integration
with it.
They'll deal with it and they'll find it
fun and they'll be happy and,
uh,
and will be gone.
So try not to be a content.
I don't know what to tell you.
All I know is I got a special coming out
that's out right now.
Special.
It's out right now.
I'm,
I'm very proud of it.
And uh,
I liked the look of it.
The whole thing.
I like the jokes that I did on it and I
hope people feel the same way,
uh,
because I'd like to continue my
privileged life here.
And this one's black and white.
No,
the last one is black and white.
This one's color rather,
right?
Each one.
Each one I do.
I have a look that I'm going for a,
the same way I try to improve as a
comedian each time is a little bit of a
different thing.
And um,
you know,
I,
I've always felt,
you know,
that we went through this horrible
period of standup specials where they,
they didn't,
it was just a complete lack of respect
for the art form is this amazing thing
that one guy,
a woman can go out there and just talk
into a microphone and people will
fucking listen to it for like,
you know,
I don't know,
an hour or so.
It,
uh,
they just started shooting it.
Everybody's looked the same and it's due
for this look.
Uh,
well I'm not going to do all my,
give you all my tricks,
but what I was go out there,
what I was going for in this one,
although that's a shitty image of it on
this thing.
But um,
there was a few concert films that I
like to look up.
Like I always try to fuck with the Hdt
hd a little bit because it's just,
it's clearer than real life.
So I try to like tone it down a little
bit.
So you gave yourself like a little
instagram filter.
Snapchat girls.
You can say that now.
Like a snapchat thing,
just making it not look like if I'm
standing in a tropical fish tank and a
clown fish is going to swim.
It's just like.
It's just like when you look at hd,
it's just like fucking like,
oh my God,
look how fucking white that tee shirt is
and you get like distracted where and I
think it makes it not look real.
Whereas if you look at,
if you look at like,
I don't know,
it's just something that I would look
at,
old concert films,
I'd look at old stand up and be like,
why does this look like this really
happened and why dissolve this shit now
looks so fake.
And a lot of it was it was.
It was just too fucking clear and it was
also like edit,
edit,
edit.
As much as it was going through and it
makes your brain reset and it rather
than drawing people in,
you're given them like like an an an
epileptic
episode.
I did my last special almost entirely
from the waist up with no edits,
very few edits.
The only time I edit is when I wanted to
show a side shot or one and I want to
show like my whole body.
That's it.
I tried to do it where you are right in
front of me just watching,
just like you would have.
You're sitting in the crowd at a comedy
show and they wanted to,
you know,
they always want to like show the
audience there was,
want to show this and cut back and
forth.
I'm like,
every time you do that you make a person
realize that they're watching a film of
their brain resets to.
Yeah.
So you were just drawn them in India.
Shit.
Like when somebody watches you do is
show you not all of a sudden up in the
balcony or turning around or swooping
in.
You got to have a little bit of that
because it doesn't have to.
It does have to be like,
you know,
sort of like a concert film.
But like,
um,
it's all,
how you,
you pick those now when you're doing
standup and you're also doing F is for
family.
Like,
you know,
we had this conversation the other day
at the store where you're talking about
how it just of swoops in
and takes all your time,
you know,
during those.
Yeah.
The heavy writing part of it.
And how much,
how much time do you spend doing that
show?
Evidence for fan,
which by the way,
it's fucking awesome.
I love that show.
It's coming out again in May.
How many episodes did you do at a time?
Well,
this time we did 10.
They gave us six.
The first uh,
the first season they gave us six
because I think they were like,
what the fuck do you guys want to do?
And then they saw it and then they,
they liked it.
And uh,
that's what I'm guessing because it was
a weird order.
It's like a half order.
So now,
um,
now we're doing 10.
Um,
so that comes out in May.
I just realized that math didn't work
out on that because it gave me six and I
still,
it was a half four but they used to do
12 but then they whittled it down to 10.
So now like when you write that,
how far in advance do you start before
you,
because it takes awhile to put it
together and to film it.
Yeah,
we're,
we're mapping out the uh,
the third if we get a third season
because it's,
you know,
it's Kinda weird,
like you just kind of put it all out at
once.
So we have to see hopefully the people
that watched it the first time come back
again and then more people come.
But uh,
as far as how that works is like,
you really,
like,
it's,
it's the war room to do a season is you
map out the season and you really have
to like work all the bugs out of it.
And,
and that's the time when you're like,
are we going to go big here?
We gonna have this more grounded.
Is this going to happen?
Is that going to happen?
And you really work out the big
emotional moments in the story lines
before you get in there.
So you can,
um,
because as you start to write in this 10
people in the room and the ideas of
flowing,
it's,
you can kind of veer off,
which can be a good thing.
It's not like it's set in stone,
like this is what we're writing,
but like you just sort of know,
like,
you know,
we're going from okay from point a to
point b than b to c and then how you get
there is sort of the art of writing it.
But like you just want to make sure that
all of a sudden,
you know,
gold aid over to c and then blah blah
blah.
If you got pete,
we've got to go back to this.
How do we correct all of this?
Um,
depending on the type of show that you
do,
you know,
I'm like ours.
I'd like to try to keep it grounded in a
certain level of reality,
but also take advantage that it is
animation so you can get a little
absurd.
But like,
um,
and it's just like a balance of that.
It's like a fucking recipe.
Like,
I,
there's too much salt here.
You got to be going to do a little bit
more of this.
So this is the first time I've gone this
far with anything.
So now I learned a lot in this second
season about that.
So we're really hammering out this this
third season and uh,
you know,
I don't know what.
I'm a total newbie.
Had you ever written anything before
like that?
Uh,
no.
I think I actually could be a decent
writer.
I'm just,
I just don't want to do it because it's
so much fucking work.
I just,
I just don't want to just sit down,
right.
This whole fucking thing.
Sent it to a studio them and be like,
change is change and do this.
Yeah.
Long ago,
all the way back to the beginning,
like,
um,
you know,
I think if I was,
if I didn't have like then because I
always have to thing in my head,
I was like,
oh,
I could just go do a fucking standup Gig
and do it real time and it's done and I
have money for my fucking ham sandwiches
for a month.
Why do I want to,
uh,
because I,
how hard writers work it.
Like it's fucking unbelievable,
like the level that,
how hard that those people work versus
like the fucking credit that they get
and shit.
So I'm,
have,
I have such a level of respect that
like,
um,
you know,
I've,
I've talked to some people and they're
like,
hey,
you want to read it like a movie script
or something like that,
which I guess I know I could do it,
but it's just like I'm going to write a
movie strict Andrew F is for family and
fucking do stand up and try to have my
specialty better than my last special.
That alone is going to take up so much
time.
And then now I'm going to be married and
be a dad.
There's like only so many fucking hours
in the day.
And then when would I get to play drums?
Right,
right.
So do I want to fucking also add that?
And if you don't play drums and you
start going a little wacky.
Yeah.
And there'll be a dick around my wife
and kids.
So I'm that way with martial arts.
If I don't do something,
some kind of workout like I like,
if someone says,
well just don't work out for a few
weeks,
that's not even on the menu,
I can't do it.
It's almost like I have to brush my
teeth,
have to work out,
I have to maintain a balance.
If I don't have that balance,
I'm,
I,
it's weird because it's just a hobby,
but I'm literally obsessed with it.
I've watched,
I've watched all these videos.
Drum covers.
I watch about it all the time.
You're,
you're,
you're balls deep.
Yeah.
But it's like,
I think things like this fucking hard.
Right?
It's fun.
It's a fun thing to do.
And uh,
yeah,
it keeps me.
It's like something he got to have
something you're looking forward to is
how as you as hard as you're working.
Like um,
I got some road gigs coming up and I am
so fucking excited to get because I,
right after I did that special.
I think I did comics come home for leary
and that's about the only road I haven't
been.
I haven't been to lax since like
November,
which is
crazy.
So
I'm,
I'm like chomping at the bit to get out
there and like last night I tried to do
an hour man.
I was just like,
Oh God,
like,
just like with all the new shit.
Where'd you go last night?
I was down in Largo,
can be at the ice house a Friday night.
Um,
you're the ice house tomorrow to with
me.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I'll be down there.
And um,
I just got to a fraud.
The Ice House is the best.
I know all the points I want to talk
about and uh,
so I just have to start talking about
them so I,
I have to go out there.
So I'm going out and doing some club
dates and uh,
you know,
I'll bring in some really funny guys in
front of me.
He bringing a Paul [inaudible],
Joe Bart,
nick,
um,
who else I got?
I got Dean del Ray up and when we do San
Jose and I'm,
you know,
I'm just,
I just,
I,
I'm,
I'm the whole thing was waiting for the
kid to come and then she showed up and
now that that's done,
now it's just
like,
you know,
I got to get out there,
dude,
I got to get.
So you're doing theater gigs.
He doing club gigs,
so he's doing clubs when I'm working out
an hour,
I mean I have to talk in front of me
now,
but I'm not going to make people deal
with all of that bullshit to watch me
work some shit out.
So you're going to San Jose.
Are you doing the Improv?
Yeah,
that's a great club.
Yeah.
So I'm going to do like,
um,
like a Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday.
It's sort of an off night kind of thing,
you know?
Uh,
and you know,
I always feel like Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday people are more forgiving.
Friday,
Saturday people like I want to show a
lot of Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesdays.
Um,
I've,
I've told people that I'm working my
shit out,
you know,
ticket prices,
aren't that bad.
And,
and uh,
um,
yeah.
And um,
it's fun to see too.
I love watching people work shit out.
Yeah.
But I'm,
I'm,
I,
I'm not one of those people that is
working to get off the road.
I fucking love the road.
I love doing the road and like,
you know,
I go to games and shit,
like I'm going to go to Carolina and
Duke game when I'm out there,
which is fucking legendary shit.
Like that's just like a one of the,
that's like a bucket list,
sporting event,
whatever sport you're into is to go
there and just experience like that
level of passion and hysteria for
college basketball.
I mean it's like,
you know,
it's an overused word but it is a
basketball Mecca.
So that's part of your fund for the
road.
Yeah,
like a day game that night.
You do the Gig?
Yeah.
And when,
as far as like drawing like this,
this rehearsal spaces that I know of
that are just.
And it's the Shit,
because I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm not in town so I don't have any
responsibility and I just go in with my
iphone and my,
all my music,
put the fucking headphones on and just
fucking go nuts for like two hours.
It's like rather than,
I guess doing the treadmill,
which I probably should do more of,
but I just do that and it's the greatest
thing ever.
So like I'll ask you if I go to
someplace and they have enough time,
you know,
I'll ask people my podcast,
hey,
if you don't have a good rehearsal
space,
because there's good ones and bad ones,
you know,
the fucking worst ones that you go.
Then the drum kits,
they're not fucking tune.
They get old heads and then everything's
been over torqued and you got to like
fucking take the sticks to try to get
them.
You know,
they get all frozen up.
Tiny thing that a lot of people that
don't get bummed out about the road is
because they have to do the road.
Like one of the beautiful things about
you,
you don't have to do the road you like
to do the road.
Like I remember one of the things that
used to really bum me out when I would
do clubs,
they would tell me that Richard,
Jenny was just in town.
He fucking hated.
He hates being on the road.
He was grumpy.
He just hated,
hated doing standup because he always
wanted to have a sitcom who was wanting
to be like the next Seinfeld and it
didn't happen for him.
So he was miserable.
But meanwhile to me he was like one of
my idols.
I was like,
scheduling one of the greatest comics
ever and he doesn't like doing it.
Like this is all I wanted to do.
I'd show up at a club and they'd be
like,
I can't believe I'm headline and I'm
here.
I'm doing it.
And then say,
yeah,
Richard.
So nice that someone's a actually having
a good time.
Richard,
Jenny was here last week and now he's so
bummed out.
Yeah,
but you never know.
They'll let scuttle button.
The club.
He could have just been in a bad moon.
Was a cut that week,
so then all of a sudden that,
you know,
the fact that he's not here to defend
whether,
whether he.
I liked it,
I mean the,
the level that that guy wrote in the
specialist that he wrote,
he had to have enjoyed it.
He enjoyed some of it,
but I was friends with his ex girlfriend
and she was telling me that that was
really the case.
He just didn't.
I was really trying to.
I know that you wouldn't have confirmed
that.
Yeah.
Well I think back then that was the
carrot though.
The carrot was always the Sitcom.
It was like that was what everybody went
for and if you didn't get that,
you felt bummed out.
Whereas somewhere along the line we
realized that's not necessarily true.
You're better off without the Sitcom.
You're better off just being a big name,
stand up comic and having a good time.
You're throwing shit.
You don't have to deal with producers
that when he came up you had to,
you had to be given a special.
You couldn't just do it.
Yeah.
And then also the network money was
crazy.
And if you could get to syndication,
you were,
you were set for life and syndication
shit.
Now,
like when Netflix,
there is no syndication,
it's just,
it's automatically syndicated.
While I was on two shows that went to
syndication,
it's not the same.
It's not what everybody thinks it is.
Like if you're one of the owners of the
show,
it's big time.
But like I was sitting news radio's in
syndication.
I mean I got,
don't get me wrong,
I got a lot of money from it,
but it wasn't like Seinfeld money,
but it goes down to like $7 checks
really quickly.
Like however that fucking math works
out.
I had to think with my buddies a like
you just take pictures of residual
checks,
like trying to beat each other.
And two of my friends got the one cent,
they all within a month.
Love.
She didn't think that exists because I
got a lot of like dollar 17.
Um,
you know,
I,
I got a,
I got a friend of mine,
I'm not going to say the name of the
fucking movie,
but like,
it's a big time fucking moving.
Everybody loves it.
And they showed it one time on a network
for 24 hours straight and he got played
for one plane because it was just one
day,
but they sold advertising for 24 fucking
hours.
They do because they just do it and then
they sit back and wait for you to sue
them.
And Are you going to go?
Is this going to be worth it to you to
go through that?
So like the zone probably 20 bucks
anyway.
Well what I learned,
unfortunately it just like the number
one commandment of the 10 commandments
that the number one that's broken I
think is stealing.
It's just an.
As far as stealing is,
you basically have,
you basically have the illegal side of
stealing in the legal side of stealing.
So any smart criminal is trying to make
his business legit so he doesn't have to
hide his fucking money anymore.
But he can continue to just rob people
fucking blind because that's basically
what happens is everybody just like.
I mean,
some of the deals that I've signed,
like for,
for Shit like it okay if you audit us,
but we're only off by like three
percent,
then you have to pay for the audit and
like you literally just built into this
deal,
a license to steal three percent plus
what I have to catch you with steel nine
for,
to basically skim like whatever,
nine percent off of this fucking thing.
And,
and they go to sleep at night and they
feel they're good people and they don't
give a fuck that they're driving a car
that,
you know,
a bunch of other people paid for and
they took the money.
They don't give a shit.
Yeah.
Legal loopholes,
legal loopholes and find print.
Uh,
it's,
it's a dirty world
starting as far as trump,
like not reporting is taxes and all that
type of shit.
It's like you can only get so mad where
it's like,
all right,
so because he figured out the game where
he's kind of like,
well I'm just robin from thieves.
Right?
Like that whole fucking bolt,
like politicians is so underpaid.
They need all these guys money to get in
there and then when they get in there
they got to hook them up and they give
him these governmental contracts in the
fact that they're allowed to just
fucking overcharged.
Like the level they do is just this
stealing.
So you're giving you like,
like I have no problem playing,
paying taxes.
What fucking drives me up the wall is
knowing that like the amount of money,
like say you give them fucking 50 grand,
like the amount of that money that's
actually going to go for the supplies to
make a school better,
to feel like a fucking pothole and then
the amount that's just going to go into
this.
Guys,
I want a shiny watch.
My wife needs fake tits fund on the
side.
That's what eats me up at night because
I,
you know,
you see what trump did where he's filed
for reelection five hours after he took
office.
No one's ever done that before.
Everybody files for reelection.
Like a year out from the reelection.
He filed for reelection five hours after
office.
That means when anybody addresses him in
any sort of a campaign ad,
they have to address him as if they're
running against him to anything because
he's already running for president
again.
He's running for president in 2008,
so he's essentially change the way they
dress.
Don't say Mr.
President.
No,
I don't know how it works,
but Mr.
President,
president,
pull it up and we'll be able to figure
out what it.
What it means.
Figure out what the guy he's organized.
Say what you want about them.
The men is organized.
Oh,
he's definitely organized.
He's mean.
He's been just juking and fucking
shucking and jiving in business for a
long fucking time,
you know,
and he knows how to get his name on
things.
You know what I mean?
Everywhere you go,
there's some giant building that's gold
and it says trump on it.
I think we're going to be all right.
We'll be all right.
I think so.
Well yeah,
he's kind of the amount of people.
He's already fucking annoyed.
You figured the midterm elections come
two years in.
He's got his shit where he's going to
sprint for fucking two years and then I
think everybody else is just going to
vote for fucking blue ties and blue bras
and the fucking next one.
Right,
and you think so?
Yes.
I mean that's what always happens after
fucking eight years of Clinton.
Then it went red and then eight years of
Bush.
This'll make it better.
Let's go over to Obama.
Obama.
Let's go back over to fucking a.
let's go back over to the
side.
I think we'd like to see someone who is
in the middle of things though.
We would really like to see someone who
has more maybe libertarian values or
someone who's more just not adequately
writer.
Clearly left
somebody a little more secure.
His insecurity is what scares me the
most.
Like tweeting.
No,
that shit he said about his daughter and
everybody.
Oh,
that was some weird sexual thing.
Like he's so fucking insecure that
people are gonna.
Think his daughter is not good looking
that he.
He says what he wants people to say and
he wasn't thinking like context.
Oh yeah,
I date or how does,
she's the greatest of the everything he
says it.
It's like the same cadence.
It's the same three things.
Like he gets like he has time to watch
snl or like if somebody's like,
oh no,
award show.
Like why are you watching the Golden
Globes?
What do you give a fuck?
What,
what Meryl Streep's Phoebe,
who gives a fuck?
Says,
yeah,
you're the leader of the free world,
man.
Fucking not good enough.
Yeah.
Look out to the ocean and see what's
coming at us,
man.
That wants to be loved up across the
board by everybody.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
It's a,
we're here.
And what's funny is by finding
fascinating as far as like the way,
if you want to be loved to behave,
to behave the way he does and uh,
you know,
really just have that,
uh,
you know,
my way or the highway,
just ram it down your throat.
Shut the fuck up.
It's just this weird.
You know,
it's weird.
It's weird that you could have that
personality and still want to be liked.
It's just like,
it's like,
do,
do you enjoy being treated like that?
Then why would you treat other people?
Um,
this way,
I don't know.
He,
I don't know his,
his ram it down their throat,
his approaches a,
a,
you like those stupid Hollywood movies
where somebody grabs a two by four when
I cleaned this town up.
Like it's just like he's going to hurt a
lot of people because there's a lot of
innocent people are going to get caught
up in the wash of a very simplistic
solution to a huge problem.
Well,
let's get rid of all of them.
You know,
like,
um,
I don't know,
but I'm just a comedian.
I don't have the fucking answers.
I just wish like,
I don't know.
What is this Jamie?
Would he pull?
Pulling up here is about why the things
that are brought up when filing early
different things.
A candidate for president is subject to
different rules than a president is
afforded different projections.
This has critics on edge and already
existing concerns about trump's business
entanglements are now heightened by
fears that US nationals could fund
funnel cash to trump through his
campaign committee trumps status as a
candidate.
You could also make it difficult for
nonprofit organizations take actions for
or against trump and his
administration's policies.
Tax Exemption.
Organizations have leeway for political
action,
have more leeway for political action
than other nonprofits,
but are still prohibited from certain
political actions.
Leading some to worry that trump's
filings could be a tactic to reduce
opposition.
Yeah.
Which it.
Cus that's legal.
That's a great move.
It doesn't.
Considering what he's done so far,
it doesn't make you feel comfortable.
I don't know,
but we'll survive.
It will survive it.
Anyway.
What do you do this to fucking
depressed.
I just can't.
You just have somebody fucking
levelheaded.
What did you want to win?
Oh God,
I liked Bernie Sanders,
but I didn't like um,
I didn't like his entire demonization of
anybody who had money was automatically.
It just was so simple and that everybody
who is broke was a fucking hero and it
just,
it was just cartoon.
Like people are way more complex than
that,
you know,
and uh,
I dunno do it to be honest with you,
it's too fucking big.
I just knew that I,
I didn't,
I didn't like Hillary or I didn't like
trump and I was praying to God that
those weren't going to be my two.
It was just like two trains fucking the
same tractors going pleased.
Don't be,
don't leave me with these two.
Could you just fucking not.
What did you not like about Hillary?
I just,
I just didn't think she was a,
I didn't trust her.
I just thought she was a big time phony
and I just felt like she would just
fucking do or say I didn't like the
fucking 2008 that she blew the bankers.
Don't worry.
I got you guys just completely doesn't
give a fuck about all the people that
are upside down in their houses and then
has the nerve to act like she's the
people's candidate,
which is really a sticking point with me
with Democrats is they fucking sit there
and they act like they're men and women
are the people.
It's like you guys are all filthy,
stinking rich to you and you guys all
end up being multimillionaires and the
bit most highest paying fucking job you
can get as the president,
which pays 500 grand a fucking year.
Okay?
And so you're over 250 grand a year,
which means you're going to get this
shit taxed out of you.
So how the fuck did you end up being
worth 40,
5,000
million dollars?
There's no way what you're doing is
above board.
Every politician crushes it in the
private sector.
It's insane.
They,
everyone goes fucking yard.
Nobody starts a business and it shits
the bed.
Like,
uh,
they,
they said the percentage of senators and
they make like,
I don't know if the 200 grand a year or
something,
I forget what it is.
And uh,
there the amount of them that are
multimillionaires.
Yeah,
the most disturbing thing is public
speaking.
When you find out that she's speaking
for the bankers and she's doing these
$250,000,
our long speeches and they're washing
their bribe money.
It's the people that paid you to get in
there.
You did what they wanted them to do and
then just like a comedian,
you get to do your college tour and they
grossly fucking over.
I used to do a bit about it and then
you're giving a speech,
they're not even listening to their city
and they're eating like a fucking deep
fried eagle,
like not even giving a fuck.
It's so overt,
like it's almost like a serial killer
that wants to get caught.
So I just felt like,
like she was just going to be more of
the same of that preaching,
this fucking rhetoric as they just keep
deregulate and shit and trump,
I feel like what he wants to do aside
from,
you know,
uh,
I,
I just think he,
I think he's at the level of rich that
he finds the government a nuisance and
he wants to deregulate everything.
So by the time he leaves,
he can put a golf course on top of a
pipeline on a fucking,
you know?
Yeah.
Indian reservation land,
native American,
like I feel like that's what he,
like.
His goals are,
uh,
beyond the bullshit that he's saying.
I think he's going in there and he
finally gets through like,
you know,
adjust the whole mixer.
So how the fuck he wants it at.
But here's the thing,
he had to win the presidency to do it
and the fucking guy did it and I have to
say it,
the storm watching that guy that he
weathered was amazing.
Yeah.
He got the,
you know,
and that people were so clearly.
I mean,
I all,
those fucking late night shows hated the
guy and they will basically campaigning
against him.
Um,
I mean,
you're old enough now that you saw like
you've seen in our lifetime,
like people going from like,
you know,
who you voted for was really like,
Whoa,
whoa,
hey,
you get into personal to now just people
like totally like overtly.
Uh,
I dunno,
there's so much,
so much hypocritical shit and I'm part
of a tube.
But like I love when people like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm like,
I was saying it to like the fucking
celebrity apprentice.
The host of that is now president,
but then yet you're watching the
Democrat and the Republican national
conventions and there's comedians and
actors speaking at them,
so it's like,
well,
what the fuck?
It's Kinda all just.
Yeah,
well it's always been a president.
Does late night talk shows and the
people running for fucking do sketches
now on snl.
Like the whole thing has just become
like this orgy clusterfuck.
It's a popularity contest and now they
got a person who actually popular who
want it.
I mean that's really what it is.
All these people that before,
like before Obama ran for office,
nobody knew who the fuck he was.
He wasn't a popular person with Donald
Trump.
Managed to do is become a popular guy
who won the popularity contest.
He was already popular.
He was already a huge figure in American
culture for decades.
Everybody knew who he was,
so he's the first guy ever to do it like
that.
And that was the thing they were saying
about Arnold,
that if arnold a diff,
there wasn't those rules that are in
place to keep arnold from running for
president because he was born in
Austria,
that he could have done it.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
it's Kinda the same thing you might be
changing in politics was when Clinton
played the saxophone on our sineal hall.
That was like a,
uh,
that was like the Beatles on the Ed
Sullivan show for like politicians going
like,
wait a minute,
that's like,
I don't have to fucking talk policy and
I just have to do something cool.
You have the sunglasses on.
And everyone's like,
this guy's cool.
Mit was one of the first.
That's right.
He had those ray bans on,
like fucking Tom Cruise.
He,
those wayfair's.
Yeah.
And he made George senior a fucking war
hero become a one term president.
Yeah.
Well that was also a little bit of,
um,
a Ron Paul,
not Ron Paul,
I'm Ross Perot,
Ross Perot,
kind of through the monkey wrench into
the gears in that election.
Remember that?
That's,
uh,
that's one of the craziest guys.
He took full up the whole half hour an
hour long spots on television,
just bought that TV station,
just bought NBC for an hour and explain
the tax problem in this country and
where your money goes.
He made more sense than it did Bush and
Clinton did.
But the thing is,
you can't get people to vote for them
because they,
they worry that they're throwing their
vote away.
I don't believe that.
I think you were encouraging more people
like that.
We remember what happened with him and
he pulled up to this.
How did it go down this fucking road?
What are we doing right era?
It's becoming like meet the press with
two peoples who pressing.
I'm pressing.
We don't know shit.
We really half ass to go on the road and
not talk about this shit because I think
people are sick of it,
which really fucking kills me.
Trying to promote my specials.
We just went down the rabbit hole for a
fucking half hour.
I'm going to try to get away from it
because I think people are going to need
a break.
They definitely need a break.
You could see it in their face and
someone brings up trump on stage.
You could see it unless you have a
really unique point of view or you're
just being silly about the whole thing.
You know,
I've seen,
I've seen people take that hard stance
left the hard left stance on stage and
it's just depressing,
you know.
I don't know.
Women's March material got any of that?
No,
I did it last night.
Conan.
I just burned it.
I made photos,
making fun of Madonna saying she just
not just saying how great she is,
it's self promotion.
How she was working her back catalog,
uh,
she wear a bra like Ooh,
I'm protesting.
So I just started doing shit like,
you know,
he wants to put a wall up between here
and Mexico.
In my world.
There are no borders border lie.
You can download this on itunes.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno,
I like when people do shit because I'm
full of shit.
So I like hypocritical behavior,
but I'm,
I'm excited to get back out on the road
and I hope people see my special.
I'm going to have to bounce out of here
because I got to get my affairs in
order.
Now that I'm a dad and also made
affairs.
Yeah.
I get my affairs in here without taking
some elk.
I got some elk for you.
Oh Great.
Absolutely.
I,
uh,
and we're going to take me on a
helicopter ride.
We got to do that.
Dude.
I haven't flown since the beginning of
November,
so I got to a.
I can do a.
let's do a gig somewhere and we'll fly.
All right.
I'm bringing an instructor though.
Okay.
I'm not taken out the Grand Joe.
Romy.
Yeah.
No,
I'll bring an instructor.
Will go fly up there and was great.
We'll go up in the forks to a weird gig
like Bakersfield or something.
Oh yeah.
It just feels great.
Yeah.
Do you do Bakersfield?
I fill up to bakersfield at a good time.
Well,
that's fucking.
That's it.
Let's,
let's,
let's do.
Pick you up at Burbank.
Just fucking take.
You want to do that?
Let's fucking do this.
Yeah.
Let's book something.
I don't feel like I got a strong our
right now.
I'm opening.
Beautiful.
Let's do that.
It can happen.
Where's your hour at?
Right now?
I'm 40 plus minutes strong and then I
can bullshit for half an hour on top of
the walking wounded child.
Fly Up,
dude.
It would be the shit.
Yeah,
do it.
Let's do
books.
That's a done deal.
German politics.
I'm sorry I'm not bringing this up
anymore.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I just wanted to see if you had to take
on it.
That was different than my take and I'm,
I'm as tired of it as you are a Gary
Vaynerchuk tonight.
Eight PM.
That'll be the next podcast.
And uh,
and we'll see you tomorrow.
Depressing.
Yes.
As individuals we can,
we can be respectful to one another.
Yeah.
Try to be a better person.
Yes.
I liked that on a positive note.
Ladies and gentleman.
And then tomorrow,
Alex Jones,
episode nine slash 11.
See Ya.